in this course you will improve your
user interface and user experience
design skills by building a mobile app
instructor joseph brendan is a great
designer and great teacher hey guys my
name is joseph brandon and in this
course i am going to show you how to
design a mobile app from scratch
now this mobile app will be a stock
investing mobile app that users can use
to invest in the stocks of companies
that they would like to invest in
so here is a demonstration of the app
that we are going to design
now over here we have the splash screen
of the app which is what's going to show
up when you launch the app
now let's go to the next page here now
this is the page where the user will
have to select their next action which
is either to log in as an existing user
or to get started as a new user
so i would go ahead and i would click on
get started just like a new user would
do
and here on this page the new user will
be required to sign up to this
application with an email address a
phone number and a password now when the
new user does that the new user will be
taken to this page where the new user
will have to enter a verification code
that's been sent to the phone number of
that new user
now when the phone number of the new
user is verified it means that the new
user is now a registered user on this
application and the next thing the user
is going to do is to click on the
proceed button here
and when the user does that the user
will be taken to the home page of the
application which is this page here and
here on the home page of this
application
over here the account balance of the
user will be displayed here
also the user will have a button here
that can be used to fund the account on
this application and right over here the
user will have a list of recent
transactions that they have carried out
on this application now coming down here
the user will see a banner here that
they can click on to get a referral link
that can be used to invite friends to
have an account on this app now at the
bottom here
we have the navigation section of this
app
currently we are on the homepage of the
app
now let's navigate to the invest page
which is the page where the user will
have the features that they can use to
invest in stocks
so i'd come here and i'd click on invest
when i do that i would be taken to the
invest page which is this
and over here on the invest page you can
see that we have a display of cash and
assets owned by the user
and right after that over here we have a
list of top stocks that the user can
invest in
and also we have the investment
portfolio of that user over here which
is a list of all the investments that
the user had made on this app
now let's say the user is trying to
invest in one of these stocks listed
here let's see this one here now if the
user clicks on it
the user will be taken to the details
page of that stock that they clicked on
and on this details page
we are going to have information about
the stock and the company that owns the
stock
now if the user likes what they see here
the user will go ahead to click on the
invest button here and when the user
clicks on that button the user will be
required to enter the amount that they
wish to invest
in that stocks with now when the user
enters the amount and the user clicks on
the proceed button here
the user will see a summary of the
investment that they are about to make
and when the user is okay with what they
see here in the summary
the user will be required to enter their
secrets pin here
and then click on the invest button here
and when the user does that it means
that the investment has been successful
so this app that i just demonstrated
here is what we are going to design in
this course from scratch now before we
start designing this app i would love to
break down the stages of our workflow
for this project
so that you can understand the execution
process of designing products that are
actual business solutions
so here are the stages of our workflow
first things first
the stakeholders of this project which
is the owner of the project or the
company we are working for
will present us with a problem that they
would want us to design for now when
they present this problem to us
they are also going to tell us about the
users
which are the people facing the problem
that they want us to design for now
after that the stakeholders will state
their expected goals for the project
now after the stakeholders present a
problem and state their expected goals
to us
the next stage of our workflow will be
for us the ux designers to empathize
with the users
now after we empathize with the users
facing the problem
we are going to create what we call a
problem statement
and after creating this problem
statement the next stage of our workflow
will be the stage where we will have to
come up with ideas that can be best
business solutions to the problems
highlighted in the problem statement
now when we are able to get an idea for
the problems in the problem statement
the next action will be for us to design
that idea into a testable prototype and
after designing that idea into a
testable prototype we will go ahead to
test the design to be sure that it is
able to solve the problems in the
problem statement so let's get to work
now i would come here in figma
and i would use a fig jam file to work
on all the analytical parts of our
workflow
so let's create a fig jam file and to do
that come here and click on the new fig
jam file button there when you do that
you have created a big jam file as easy
as that and i would like to mention that
if you are new to using fig jam you have
nothing to worry about it's a really
simple tool to use
just follow along and you'd see that at
the end of this course you'd be good
with using fig jam so i'll close this
and the next thing i'll do after
creating a fig jam file is to give the
fig jam file a name so i would call this
stocks big jam you can call it whatever
you want to call it now after giving
this big jam file a name
the next thing to do is to outline the
stages of our workflow here in fig jam
so let's do that so first things first
i'll zoom in to 200 i would come here to
zoom in and i would select zoom to 200
percent here and when i zoom into 200
percent i would use a square shape here
to write down a headline for a workflow
so i would keep this there
i would select the text tool now so that
i can write my text and i would say
workflow stages
then i would come here and i would align
the text to the left
and i'll change the color of the
rectangle to this
and that's okay
so the next thing i'll do is to have a
sticky note where i'll outline the
workflow stages in
so to create a sticky note in fig jam
i would come here and i would select the
sticky note tool here when i select it i
would come here and i would click on the
fig jam canvas to have this now let's
select this and let's
expand the width to align with our
sticky note
so first things first i'll change
the color of my sticky note to this
then i would click on this add text
placeholder here so that i can write
down all of those workflow stages that i
talked about so i would like to make
this a list
and i would like it to be a bulleted
list so i would come here and i would
select the bulleted list property here
then i would write down the first
workflow stage which is this it says
stakeholders present the problem and the
users facing the problem now i would
create another
list item which is going to be the next
stage of our workflow and that's going
to be where the stakeholders will define
the goals for this project so i would
say define goals let's come here let's
create some space here
now let's outline the next stage of our
workflow after the goals are defined
we the ux designers will empathize with
users
so let's come here and let's create this
space also now after we the ux designers
empathize with the users the next stage
of our workflow will be where we are
going to create a problem statement so i
would say create
problem statements so let's come here
let's create this space
now after we create a problem statement
the next stage of our workflow will be
the stage where we are going to come up
with an idea that can solve the problems
listed in the problem statement
now after we come up with a best idea
that can solve the problems in the
problem statement the next stage of our
workflow will be the stage where we are
going to design that idea into a
testable prototype so i would say design
prototype here and after we design that
idea into a testable prototype we are
going to move over to the next stage of
our workflow which is going to be the
stage where we are going to test
that idea that we have designed into a
prototype so i would just call that test
and now
have that
spaced now we have outlined our workflow
stages here so just to make this better
i would select all of these and i would
make all of the text bold
to have that i would come here
i would select this text and i'll make
it bold also
now i'll zoom back to 100
to see what we have and this is okay so
i would use the hand tool which is this
you can come here to click on it to
select it or just press the h key on
your keyboard to have it selected
and i would grab and shift our canvas to
this point so now we have outlined our
workflow stages here right now the next
thing to do is for us to outline all of
the actions that will be taken under
each
of this workflow stage so this means
that we are now going to break down each
of this stage one after another so that
we know what actions to take
at each of this stage and how to
optimize for our results
so i would select the move tool here by
clicking on it or by pressing the v key
on my keyboard to select it and i would
come here i would select the square tool
there so that i can create this shape
like this
and over here i would write a text
inside this shape and that text will be
this first stage i would select all of
this text here then i'll use ctrl c if
you are using a mac it's command c i
would use that to copy that text and
i'll paste it inside
this square shape like this now i would
expand this
to this point now this is the first
stage of our workflow right i would come
here now and i would have a sticky note
here right under that
now in this sticky note i would write
out what's going to happen at this stage
which is the first stage of our workflow
now this stage is the stage where the
stakeholders will present the problem to
us and also let us know about the users
that they want us to design for
so in this course i would like us to
assume that
we have a stakeholder somewhere or we
have a company somewhere that wants us
to design an app that you can use to
invest in stocks for them right so i
would paste this in here in this sticky
note
which says users
find it really hard to invest in stocks
using existing investment apps due to
information overload and complex
presentation of information on the apps
now who are the users the users are
stock investors
in nigeria so this so having this here
means that the stakeholders
have presented us with a problem and the
users facing the problem so this is
sorted so let's change the color of the
sticky node
something like this to differentiate it
from this one here
and let's come here let's change this
to that to differentiate it also so this
is the first stage of our workflow and
we have seen what's going to happen here
at this stage
so let's look at the next stage here
which is the stage where the
stakeholders will define the goals of
the project
so i would come here
i would select this and i'll duplicate
it to duplicate is ctrl d if you are
using a mac it's command
d so i'll duplicate this and i'll have
it stay here i will take out this text
inside this shape
and i would write
define goals there i can have in
brackets
say by stick holders
so i'll keep this here now i would come
here also i would duplicate this and i'd
have it stay right under this shape
which is a square shape right so inside
this sticky note i'll take all of these
out
and i would also assume that we have
stakeholders somewhere who sent us the
goals that they want for this project so
let's assume that
the stakeholders sent us
this as their goal
and it says
research and help users simplify every
task
needed to make a stock investment
so what we have here so far is this the
stakeholders
have presented us with a problem and the
user is facing the problem
and they have gone ahead to define their
expected goal for this project and the
expected goal is
that they want us to research and help
users simplify every task needed to make
a stock investment so let's move over to
the next stage of our workflow which is
the stage where we the ux designers will
have to empathize with the users facing
the problem
so i would come here
i'll duplicate this i would have this
here
and i would say empathize
now i'd have this here also
and i'll take out all we have here
and at this empathize stage this is
actually the stage where we the ux
designers will now get to work
so what do we do at this stage what are
the actions that we need to carry out at
this stage so that we can say that we
have properly empathized with the users
facing the problem so
what we are going to do is to interview
the users face to face or send out
surveys digitally to the users
the purpose for that is so that we can
understand the problems from the
perspective of the people facing the
problem now after that we are going to
create what we call user personas all
under this empathize stage
so i would make this a list
just like this to have that organized
properly and when we are done with the
empathy stage by carrying out these two
actions here the next thing we are going
to do is to move over to the next stage
of our workflow which is the stage where
we will have to create a problem
statement
so i would come here i would have this
here and i'll change that to create
problem statements
and i'll have this stay here so at this
stage where you the ux designer will be
needed to create a problem statement
what you do to create a problem
statement
is easy just state the problem of the
users with all you have gathered from
the previous stage which is the empathy
stage so after you have interviewed the
users to understand the problems from
their perspective and you have created
user personas for each of the user what
you do is you would use all of that data
to properly state the problem that the
users are facing now when you create the
problem statement which is you stating
the problem properly the next thing you
do is to move to the next stage of our
workflow which is the ideal stage
now when you get to the idea stage let's
have this here
when you get to the idea stage the
actions that you take at the idea stage
a simple actions
all you'd have to do is this
launch a brainstorming session then
during the brainstorming session vote
for the best idea when you vote for the
best idea
select the idea with the highest vote
and there you have gotten an idea that
you can then
take to the next stage of our workflow
which is the stage where we are going to
design that best idea into a testable
prototype
so before we go there let's select this
and let's make it a list like this
now
let's come here and let's
look at the next stage here which is the
design prototype stage
and
when you get to this stage what are the
actions
that you would need to take for you to
properly design
a workable prototype we are going to
look at the actions now so i would have
this stay here
i'll take all of this out
and
the actions that we are going to take to
properly design a prototype
are all of this
first things first we are going to
create an information architecture for
the best idea that we got from the idea
stage
when we create that information
architecture we are going to use that
information architecture to create what
we call a low fidelity prototype
now after we create that low fidelity
prototype we are going to test the low
fidelity prototype and when the test is
successful we are going to go ahead to
create a high fidelity prototype
for that best idea that we got from the
ideal stage
now after we create the high fidelity
prototype
we are going to move over to the next
stage of our workflow which is the stage
where we are going to need to test that
high fidelity prototype
so i would come here i would have this
here i would say test prototype
and i'll bring this here i can just say
usability testing here
and that's all
let's come here and let's make all of
this a list
and that's okay so what we have here is
a proper breakdown of our workflow so i
like to connect all of these so that
we understand that these stages are to
be followed one after another so i would
select the connector tool here you can
see where my mouse cursor is on click on
it to select it i would come here i
would select this point click hold and
drag
and i would connect it with this other
point here i would select this also
connect it here
i'll do that for all of these other
items also
i'll have all of them connected so we
are going to design our product by
following the breakdown of this workflow
so now that we have outlined our
workflow stages and we have broken down
all of our workflow stages like this
the next thing we need to do is to start
executing
each of the actions that we have
outlined here one after another
so let's get to work
so the first stage of our workflow here
is the stage where the stakeholders will
present us with the problem and the
users facing the problem right
and as you can see that stage is sorted
because
i assumed that
a stakeholder presented us with this
problem and the users facing the problem
so this stage is sorted
now over to the next stage which is the
stage where the stakeholders will state
their expected goals for the project and
that is sorted also
as you can see here i also assumed that
the stakeholders
has stated their expected goals to us
which is to research and help users
simplify every task needed to make a
stock investment now over to the next
stage which is the stage where we the ux
designers will get to work and
that is the empathize stage and under
the empathize stage here these are the
actions that we need to take
the first action is to interview the
users face to face or send out surveys
digitally to the users now in this
course since this is a lesson i can't
show you how to set up a face-to-face
interview but i'll show you how to
create a digital survey using google
forms so let's do that
so i would come here in my browser
and i would open a new tab then come
here i would click on this menu icon
here so that i can access my google apps
i would scroll down and i would click on
forms here and when i do that i would
come here and i would click on blank
there then a blank form will be created
for me now i would give this form a
title i can call it stock app ux
survey
and that's it
i'll come here also and i'll give the
form a name so i can call the form stock
app ux survey also or you can give it
any name at all that you want to give it
now the next thing i would need to do is
to have a form description just to
describe what this survey form is all
about
so i would come here and i would have
this
and it says this survey is carried out
by best technologies and it is aimed at
improving the experience of users who
want to invest in stocks from an app
without having complex steps now you can
come up with a better description when
you are doing this in real life now
after that i would start passing in the
fields that i want the users to give me
a response to and the first field i
would have here will be an email field i
would like to collect the email address
of everyone that will take part in this
survey so that's going to be my first
field here so to collect email addresses
i would come here i'll click on settings
here then i'll expand responses here
you can see the responses section here i
would expand it
then in front of this collect email
addresses option here i'll turn on this
toggle button
just like that and that's sorted now
when i come back here you would see that
we have an email field here which is
going to require the user
to enter their email address here and as
you can see there is a red asterisk
there
showing that this is a mandatory field
which means that
anyone taking this survey must have to
enter their email address now let's move
over to the next question that we are
going to ask anyone taking this survey
and that's going to be us asking them to
enter their full name yeah so i would
come here when i typed that in i would
change this from multiple choice to
short answer just like that then i would
come here and i would turn on this
toggle button to make this field a
required field meaning that anyone
taking this survey must have to enter
their full name and that sorted so i
would come here and i would click on the
plus sign here to add another question
just like that then this question will
be
country of residence now this is
important because coming from what the
stakeholders presented to us as a
problem and the users facing the problem
we could see that the stakeholders are
actually trying to solve a problem for
people living in nigeria so it is
important to ask anyone taking this
survey from where they reside so if
someone from germany takes this survey
by mistake or happenstance then it means
that when we are collecting the data
from the survey we are actually going to
ignore that person's impute because the
person is not based in nigeria so that's
why it's going to be important to ask
this question so i would come here and i
would make this required also now make
sure this is set to short answer also
then i would come here and i would click
on this button to add another question
now this question is going to be us
asking anyone taking this survey to
enter their age and this is also
important because usage of apps and the
experience behind the usage of apps
differs by age range so i would ask this
question and i would set this to short
answer then i would make this a required
question so i would go ahead and i would
add another question option here so that
i can ask my next question which is
going to be us asking whoever is taking
the survey to enter their profession
i would keep this set short answer and
i'll make this required then i would add
another question here and this question
is going to be us asking have you
invested
in stocks
from a mobile app now this is going to
be a yes or no answer and google forms
automatically suggest this because i
have a question mark at the end of the
question now i would come here and i
would click on yes as my first option
and i would click on no
as my second option and that's going to
be fine then i would come here and i
would make this a required question then
i would add another question here
which is going to be
select the goals you always love to
achieve when investing in stocks from a
mobile app now i would have that in
brackets
saying select more than one now i would
come here and i'll make sure this is a
check box option now me making this a
check box option is because i want the
person taking the survey to select more
than one answer so i would come here
i'll type in my first option which is
going to be
invest quickly my second option will be
fund my wallet with more than one option
the third option will be withdraw
my dividends
quickly the first option will be easily
access transaction history and the final
option here will be to save time so this
is me asking anyone taking this survey
to tell us what they would love to
achieve more when using a mobile app to
invest in stocks
so these are all the options that they
can choose from and from the answers
they select we the ux designers will
understand what to focus on when
designing and what not to focus on when
designing so i would come here and i
would make this a required question also
and that's fine and i would add another
question here which is going to be me
asking anyone taking this survey this
question it says
select the frustrations you face
when investing with the app you are
currently using to invest so i would
also give them the option to select more
than one answer here and i'll have check
boxes selected here so the first option
here will be
complex and unnecessary graphs the
second one will be
long time to invest and
the third option will be excessive
ambiguity of information the fourth
option will be on friendly user
interface and the final option will be
difficulty in funding wallet or account
now this is us asking whoever is taking
this away to tell us the problems that
they have with any investment app that
they are currently using now from what
they would select here we the ux
designers will understand the problems
to tackle and what to completely avoid
when designing our own
investment app so i would come here and
i would make this a required question
also and the final question or the final
request i would have in this survey is
to have the person taking the survey to
upload their picture now this is not
going to be a mandatory field we are
going to make it optional if they like
they upload if they like they don't
so i would come here i would click on
the plus sign there to add a question
and i would come here and i would select
file upload
now i would come here and i'll click on
continue and i would come here and i
would say
upload
your image
and i'll make sure this is not set to
required that's because i want it to be
optional and that's fine so at this
stage i'd like for us to preview this
survey to see how it will look like when
it is sent out to the people facing the
problem so i would come here and i would
click on this button here you can see
where my mouse cursor is on when i click
on it i would have a preview of the
survey and this is it here it looks okay
so let's come back here and let's click
on send when you click on send you'd
have this pop-up show up here now you
would come here and you would edit this
message just in case you want to send
this as an email to whichever person you
want to send it to so you would come
here and you'd say
vest technologies there you put in your
own company's name best technologies
has invited you to fill in a survey for
ux research or whatever you want to see
there
and that's fine now this option is only
when you want to send this survey form
as an email directly to people you would
come here and you type in their email
address let's say you type this in you'd
use comma then type in the next email
and the next email and the next email
now if you don't want to send this as an
email you have the option of sending
this also as a link
now this option will make it possible
for you to put this link up on your
social media or send it through whatsapp
or send it through any other app to the
public so that anyone that stays in
nigeria can stumble upon the link and
take the survey now to do that come here
and click here when you click there you
would see the link here now come here
and click on this check box that says
shorten url when you do that you would
have a shorter link
now you would come here and just
copy this link
when you copy it then you can post it on
linkedin you can post it on twitter you
can post it anywhere you want to post it
you can send it to anyone and when they
click on the link they will be taken to
the survey form for them to take the
survey now when they take this away you
will be having the option
to see the responses here all you do is
come back to the form click on responses
and you'll see all of the responses over
here currently i have zero responses so
what's going to happen is i would take
this survey myself i'll take it twice so
that i would have two responses and i
would use those two responses to
continue our research process now take
note in real life you'd have more than
two responses so i would post this video
here i would go ahead and i would take
the survey myself twice so i have taken
the survey by myself twice
and these are my responses as you can
see here we have this field that says
who has responded and these are the
emails of the people that have responded
and these are their full names and all
of that now
this summary tab here in the responses
section
will just give you a full summary of all
the responses
now for you to attend to one response at
a time come here and click on the
individual tab here when you do that
then you can come here and select the
individual responses based on their
email addresses currently this email is
and at xyz.com and
and all of these responses here all of
these answers are the answers of this
particular user if you want to see the
answer from any other user come here and
select that with the email of that user
if i select chucks at xyz.com
you would see that i would have all of
this show up here now as you can see
here this is the email of chooks and
this is the full name of chooks chucks
ek
and
the country and city of residence is
nigeria enugu the age is 24 the
profession is importer have you invested
in stocks yes have you invested in
stocks from a mobile app yes
select the goals you always love to
achieve when investing in stocks from a
mobile app and chuck said to invest
quickly
to fund my wallet with more than one
option to easily access transaction
history and to save time
now the next question here is select the
frustrations you face when investing
with the app you are currently using to
invest and chooks
says
long time to invest complex and
unnecessary graphs
excessive ambiguity of information and
non-friendly user interface
now for the other user which is an
you can see the email of the user here
and the name of the user is anne folake
and the country and city of residence is
nigeria lagos i know in my initial
survey form i did not include city of
residence actually but i just had to
include that so that i can target the
particular location where the user is
staying and the age is 24
the profession is mural artist
have you invested in stocks yes have you
invested in stocks from a mobile app yes
select the goals you always love to
achieve when investing in stocks from a
mobile app and anne says to invest
quickly to fund my wallet with more than
one option easily access transaction
history save time and for this question
here and select long time to invest
complex and unnecessary graphs excessive
ambiguity of information and
non-friendly user interface now at the
bottom here you would also see that
the date of submission and the time of
submission is recorded
so i'll come back here and i would also
like to let you know that you can you
can export this response to a
spreadsheet
now i would advise you that if you want
to do that come here click on summary
then click on create spreadsheet
when you do that you would have this
option to select create a new
spreadsheet or select existing
spreadsheet now if this is your first
time just create a new spreadsheet now
i'll keep that now i'll keep that
selected come here and i'll click on
create
when i do that i'll have a new tab
launched and as you can see all of my
responses has been exported into this
spreadsheet now you can also choose to
come here and make your analysis
from this spreadsheet
and that's okay so after you create your
surveys and send them out and
the users or the people that you sent
them out to
send in their responses you would go
ahead to create what we call user
personas for each and every user that
sent in a response
so at this stage i would like us to see
how to create user personas and take
note creating user personas is an action
you take while you are at the empathize
stage
now just understand that
this empathize stage is the stage where
you get to know the users better and
understand their frustrations better and
that's because it's only when you
understand a problem better that you can
come up with a better solution for that
problem so let's go ahead and let's see
how to create user personas for each of
the user that sent in a response to our
survey so i would come here now and i
would select
the text tool here and i'd have this
here i would say
user personas
i would keep that selected i'll change
this text from a normal text
to a sub heading text
and i'll make this bold
then i would come here and i'll change
the color of this text to that so this
is going to be our user persona section
let's duplicate this
let's come up here let's call this
section
workflow breakdown however you want to
call it it's fine that's okay
so i'll scroll down to the user persona
section and the first thing i would have
here is the image of the user that i
want to create a persona for so i would
come here i would select
the square tool here to have a square
shape here which i am going to use to
place the image of that user in now this
is necessary whether the user sends in
an image or not you can just have these
here if the user does not send in an
image then you leave this blank go ahead
and do the rest but if the user sends in
an image then you place the image in
here now there is one way to place an
image into a shape here in fig jam all
you have to do is keep the shape
selected right click on it then
go to plugins and use the unsplash
plugins for that so i would come here i
would launch that plugin and i would
come in here and i'll type in african
woman so i can have an image of an
african woman show up there so i would
come here and i would select this and
that's okay so the next thing to do is
to have all of these details about this
person who has this image now the name
here is anne folake the country and city
is nigeria lagos the age is 24
professional mural artist now over here
i would say anne is a mural artist
resident in lagos nigeria and is also a
stock investor who invests in stocks
with existing stock investing apps in
nigeria and this is like a summary about
her personality now i'd go ahead and i'd
highlight her frustrations with the
existing investment apps that she used
in nigeria and i'd also highlight the
goals that she aims to achieve with an
investment app so i would come here and
i would have this here i would paste
this and over here these are the things
that she wishes that she had as an
experience with an investment app and
these are her current frustrations now
all of these details
about anne was gotten from the response
that she gave us
when she took this survey that we
created so you can see how this connects
so let's go ahead and let's create a
user persona for the other user that
took the survey so that is going to be
chooks so i would come here i would have
this shape here and i would run the
unsplash plugin on that shape and
i would type in african man
and i would go with this here and that's
okay so i would have this here for
chooks
this is his name and his country and
city age profession and all of that
i would also highlight his goals
and frustrations and that's fine still
so what we have done so far is this we
have concluded the empathize stage
we have gotten to know about the problem
from the perspective of the users and we
have created user personas for each user
that took our survey so we are going to
move ahead to the next stage of our
workflow here which is the stage where
we are going to create a problem
statement based on all we have gathered
during the empathize stage now this
really makes sense because you can
create a better problem statement when
you understand the problem better and
the way to understand the problem better
is to empathize with the people facing
the problem and that's what we have done
so let's go ahead and let's create a
problem statement based on what we have
learned so i'll duplicate this
i would come here i would say problem
statement
and for me going by all we have learned
from the empathize stage this is my
problem statement
my problem statement states that users
are frustrated with existing investment
apps as a result of excessive ambiguity
of information and complex steps these
concepts negatively affect the
experience of these users now this is my
problem statement and this is the
problem that i'll try to solve so if we
come up here
you would see that we have empathized
with the users and we have created a
problem statement so the next stage of
our workflow is the ideate stage which
is the stage where we have to come up
with an idea that can solve the problems
that we have in the problem statement
and what actions are we to take at this
stage so at the idea stage the first
thing we are going to do is to set up a
brainstorming session where we are going
to invite other designers product
managers business managers lawyers
software engineers and so on and so
forth now when we invite all of these
people we are going to present them with
enough information about the problems in
the problem statement and ask them to
come up with ideas that can possibly
solve the problems in the problem
statement now when each and every one of
these people that we have invited come
up with an idea the next thing to do is
to read out all of these ideas to
everyone and call a vote for the best
idea now the idea with the highest votes
should be selected and when that is done
it means that you are ready to move to
the next stage of our workflow which is
the stage where you would have to design
that idea into a testable prototype so
before we move over to this stage here
i'd like to come here i would also
highlight that this stage is the ideal
stage this is the ideal stage and
since this is going to be a
brainstorming session stage and
obviously i can't have a brainstorming
session here in this lesson it's going
to be something that you'd set up with
the people you want to set it up with be
it on zoom discord beat real life anyhow
you want to set it up that's fine so
i'll just highlight this stage here and
what i'm going to do is
i would assume that i conducted a
brainstorming session offline just so
that we can learn better and i would
also assume that during that
brainstorming session we arrived at an
idea so i would have this here selected
idea and i would paste
this as
a selected idea now this is the selected
idea for this course it says create an
investment app where graphs are
represented with text
where users will have the option to fund
their account and wallet via bank
transfer or their debit cards
where recent transaction history will be
easily accessible
and
where plain and easy to understand
english will be mostly used now if you
look at this idea you would see that
this idea solves the problems that we
have in this problem statement and this
problem statement was gotten from all we
learned
during the empathize stage and we were
able to learn all we learned during this
stage because we created a survey form
and sent out the survey to users so you
can see how everything connects
so now that we have an idea that we can
use to solve the problem the next stage
here is the design prototype stage and
at this stage the actions that we need
to take are all of these first things
first we need to create an information
architecture for this best idea that was
selected during the idea stage so i
would come here i would scroll down to
this point
and i would have this
here i would say
information architecture now before we
create the information architecture
let's understand what an information
architecture is and
why it is important to create one so the
information architecture of a mobile app
is
the way you organize and arrange
information on the mobile app that will
help the users of that mobile app to
accomplish their task on that mobile app
without a bad experience
so it is in the information architecture
that you decide what features and what
information will exist on each page of
the app and each step of the app so
let's go ahead and let's create an
information architecture for this idea
now the way to start creating your
information architecture is to first of
all define the goals of the users who
will use the app then define the task
that the users have to complete to
achieve their goals on the app so i
would come here and i would have this
here so this here is the goal of the
user to invest with a good experience
now the user task here are the actions
that the user will have to take to
achieve this goal now what are the tasks
the user will have to sign up to the
application as a new user or log in as
an existing user then fund their account
or their wallet then use the fund that
they have in their account or wallet to
invest in any stock of their choice so
if they can accomplish this task this
task and this task it means that they
have achieved their goal on that app so
after defining the goals of the user and
stating the task that the user has to
complete to achieve that goal we are
going to go ahead to create our
information architecture flow and for
the sake of time i would speed up this
process and i would explain it so that
you can understand so what we have here
is our information architecture flow
and i'll zoom in so that i can break
down this flow one after another and
also show you how to come up with a flow
like this this is the start point of the
flow this is where the user launches the
app so when the user launches the app
the user will have two options one to
sign up and one to log in so let's go
with the sign up flow here now if the
user is trying to sign up the user will
be required to sign up with their email
address phone number and password and
after this step the user will have to
verify their phone number now after the
phone number is verified the user will
be taken to the home page of the
application
when the user gets to the home page of
the application the user will have all
of these options here and the first
route or the first option here will be
the menu icon which will be on the home
page the user will also have the account
balance displayed on the home page the
user will have a fund account option
that they can use to fund the account
still on the home page and still on the
home page the recent transactions by the
user will be displayed there on the home
page
now still on the home page we are going
to have a referral banner still on the
homepage we are going to have an invest
route that the users can take if they
wish to invest in stocks now still on
the home page we are going to have a
transact
option just in case the user wishes to
deposit or withdraw so all of this is on
the home page now let's look at the flow
of the first item here which is the menu
icon now if the user clicks on the menu
icon which is on the home page the user
will see all of these options recent
transactions card management investment
portfolio request statement and settings
now just for the sake of those who don't
know what a menu icon is if you go to an
app or a website using your mobile phone
you would always have this
icon here at the top that when you click
on it you would have a drop down or you
would have a menu bar sliding from the
left or from the right now that's what
we call a menu icon and most mobile apps
have that
so this is going to be all that will
show up when the user accesses the menu
icon route now for the account balance
all that's going to show up there is
available balance and that's all now for
the fund account option this is the flow
the user will have to choose a method
and this is important for the experience
because from our user research it was
clear to us that the users actually want
an experience where they would have the
option to fund their accounts with more
than one option so when they choose a
method then they would go ahead to fund
the account with that method that they
have chosen so that's for the fund
account route right now for the recent
transactions route
all the user will have when they access
a recent transaction will be the
transaction details and that's okay
now we have the referral banner option
here and when the user accessed that
route they would have a referral promo
code that they can copy you know and
send to a friend to join the app for all
of that and all of that and that's fine
now we have the invest route here when a
user accesses this route the user will
see
list of stocks that they can invest in
and will also see their stock portfolio
that they had invested in so if the user
access
one of the stocks that's been listed the
user will see
the detail for that stock and if they
like
what they see in the detail they will go
ahead to invest and that's a good flow
so if you come here we have this route
here which is the transact route when
the user accesses this route the user
will have the option to make a deposit
which is also like funding the account
you get and the user will also have the
option to make a withdrawal from their
account so this is just the basic
information architecture flow for this
app and it is always important for you
to create this information architecture
so that you would understand and
organize the steps that the user will
take on the app
it is also important so that you can
also streamline the core features that
each page of your app will have now if
you remember that was the signup route
the login route is still the same
because all you have to do here to log
in is just enter your email address and
your password then you'll be taken to
the home page still when you get to the
home page every other theme is the same
so that's that if you have any questions
on the information architecture here
draw my attention to it and i'll be
there to help so if you come here now
in our flow breakdown you'd see that
under the design prototype stage we have
created our information architecture the
next action at this stage is to create a
low fidelity prototype of the best idea
using the information architecture
now before we do that i would love to
explain what a low fidelity prototype is
so a low fidelity prototype is a dummy
version of your final design for an app
now the question you may ask is this why
do we need to design a dummy version now
this is it designing a dummy version is
important because at this stage of
trying to figure everything out
your design and your design process can
be subject to lots of changes and inputs
from the stakeholders
now it's just like building a dummy
house first before you build the main
house now if you use paper to build a
dummy house first
before building the main house
it's going to be a lot easier when the
owner of the house comes to make a
correction or comes to make a change
since it's a paper you don't have much
to lose all you have to do is just tear
it and put it back in seconds but if you
go ahead to build the main house first
and the owner of the house comes and
says okay i don't want this design here
i don't want that there it means that
you'd have to break down that part of
the house and rebuild that part of the
house with all of the resources that you
have put into building that part of the
house and that's going to be a lot more
hectic compared to you using a paper to
just build a prototype or a model of the
house so that's basically what a low
fidelity prototype is and that's why it
is important for you to have a low
fidelity prototype then take that to the
stakeholders for correction and changes
and inputs and all of that
now when the low fidelity prototype has
been accepted and agreed on then you can
go ahead to design the real app itself
which is the high fidelity prototype
so let's go ahead and let's see how to
create a low fidelity prototype of our
best idea so we are going to do that
using a figma design file so i would
come here i would go to figma and i
would create a new design file and i
would call this
stock investment app and i would come
here and i would rename the page one to
low fidelity and this page is going to
contain all our low fidelity screens
so let's go ahead and let's start
so to design low fidelity screens is
easy and it is easy because you don't
need a design system for that like you
don't need a style library to do that
you don't need a component library to do
that you don't need all of that all you
have to do is focus on the user task so
if you come here you'd see that a user
task on this app
is to sign up a login fund your account
or wallet and invest and if a user
accomplish all of these tasks it means
that the user will achieve their goal on
this app which is to invest in stocks so
we are going to design our low fidelity
screens
around these user tasks
so let's come back here in our figma
design file and let's see what it is to
create low fidelity screens all you have
to do is select the frame tool then go
with any
template of your choice i would go with
iphone 13 pro max and i would have that
so the next thing i'll do is to just
come here
and since this is going to be the
splash screen i'll just have this logo
stay here i'll align it to the center
horizontally and to the center
vertically then i would go ahead to
create the login screen the sign up
screen and all of that
and actually the way i like doing it is
this i like to segment the screens into
categories using the user task
this section or this segment should be
for authentication screens so i would go
ahead speed up this process and have
other screens here then i'll explain how
i came about all of them now before i do
that i may have missed something here i
know some people who are new to fig jam
may not understand how these
connectors are created now all you have
to do is use the connector tool select
it
click on the point
then
you connect it anyhow you want to
connect it you can take your connector
anywhere connect any ship that you are
trying to connect and that's fine and
when your connector is created you can
actually play around with it you can
click on it to select it grab that point
take it up take it down anyhow you want
to play around with it it's fine
now you can also select the connector
and change the color of the connector
just like this so all of these
connection lines were created using the
connector tool here so let's go back to
our figma design file and i'll pause
this video here and come back with all
of our low fidelity screens then i'll
explain further so what we have here are
low fidelity screens for the
authentication task
so let's zoom in as you can see here we
have the splash screen which is this now
after the splash screen we have this
screen where the user will have to
choose their authentication action which
is either to log in or to sign up now to
create this button here you don't need
to use an auto layout or any of that all
you just have to do is
select the rectangle tool like this
create it anyhow you want to create it
then
come here select the text tool and you
can just say login or sign up or
whatever you want to have there
just like this that's how i created this
and i did not have to come up with a
column and it's advisable for you not to
use colors when creating your low
fidelity screens and that's because if
you have colors chosen it may distract
the stakeholders when you are presenting
the low fidelity screens to them at this
stage all you should focus on
is the user experience so having colors
or making the low fidelity screens look
good may distract the stakeholders away
from the user experience so that's how i
came up with the buttons there and here
also these input fields i just use a
rectangle
the rectangle tool to create a rectangle
shape there i added a stroke
and i took out the fill color and i had
that then i had a text inside there
saying email just like that and this
button we know how to do that i
duplicated all of this and i had one
more field here for the phone number and
my button is still here then here we
have this field for a verification code
and over here i have the verify button
that's okay so all of these screens here
are for the authentication task now
let's scroll down to the next task which
is going to be the fund wallet task and
that task actually will happen from the
home page so that's why i created a low
fidelity version of our home page so you
can see that we don't have too much of
information here so if i scroll down
you'd see that i have the fund account
popup action here now this element is
going to show up when a user clicks on
fund account here when they do that this
popup will show up for them to choose
the method that they want to fund the
account with
and that's okay so this is easy to
create just have a rectangle
like this and have your text inside of
it
then the background of this navigation
section is also a rectangle that i had
across the screen like this and i
changed the color to something like this
just like that that's easy
so over here this is a rectangle also
with a text on it and i have a rectangle
here with a corner reduce of 16px and
that's okay here we know how to create a
button and this is just text now for
this icon here i got that from an icon
plugin i used
the feather icons plugin
to have that sorted
so this task is complete we have the
font account button here
which if a user clicks on it
you'll have this popup show up like this
now let's move over to the next
task on our app
and the next task here is
to invest so if i come here and i scroll
down you'd see that i have these screens
for the invest task now this is the
section for that we have this page here
we have this icon we have this text here
now i have
this section which is like
the list of stocks to invest in i have
this search bar here i have this search
field here which is also easy to create
all you have to do is create a rectangle
give it a corner reduce of let's say 16
or let's say 8 16 is a lot then come
here take out the fill color and give it
a stroke color and you have that then
you have a text inside there that's
really easy to create then i have the
list of stocks here so i just have a
rectangle here also with this text on
top of it so it's also easy to create
all you have to do is just have
something like this then give it a
corner reduce of 16
then
take the color down a bit to this point
then have your text written on top of it
plot away then keep this here then have
this plus two three four percent
there or any number that you're okay
with so that's how i created this and if
you scroll down you'll see that we have
the your stock portfolio section which
has this also we know how to create this
and over here we have
the navigation section and that's okay
so the next page here let's zoom out a
bit the next page here is the stock
details page now this is us assuming
that a user is interested in this stock
here you can see where my mouse cursor
is on so if a user is interested in this
talk and the user goes ahead to click on
it
this details page will show up for this
stock showing the details of that stock
and
the company that owns the stock you'd
have the company logo here
and you'd have the stock percentage and
all of that there you'd have the
interest for that stock minimum cap
volume about the company the valuation
rank and all of that
then you'd have an invest button here
and i think by now we know how to create
all of the elements here
now
if a user clicks on the invest button
they would go to this page where they
would have to enter the amount that they
wish to invest in that stocks with and i
believe on this page here we know how to
create all of the elements
that we have here now if a user clicks
on the next button here after entering
the amount they wish to invest in that
stocks with the user will be taken to
the next page here which is going to
display the summary of the investment
they're about to make over here they
would have the amount that they typed in
here display here the minimum cap the
interest value and so many other details
and so many other details that are not
listed here now if the user is okay with
that the user clicks on the proceed
button and the next page that user will
be taken to is the success page
indicating that that investment is
successful now the user will have the
option to click on the back to home
button here and that's that it means
that that task which is the invest task
has been successful so for us to
properly present
low fidelity screens like this for
testing and for impute and for opinions
and for all of that for us to properly
do that
it means that we need to make a
prototype of these low fidelity screens
so that we can present them properly for
testing and for impute from the
stakeholders so let's go ahead and let's
do that i'll click on the prototype
option here
so let's start with the splash screen
so i would select i would click on the
splash screen to select it
when the
splash screen is selected you'd have
this point here all you have to do is
click on it hold it and drag it to the
screen
of destination so i would want the users
to go from the splash screen to this
screen here
now when i connect
this
splash screen to this other screen here
you'd see that figma will bring up this
interaction details card for us so that
we can set
the mode of our interaction so over here
i have the on click event
and the action for that on click event
is a navigate to action so what this
means is that
when the splash screen is clicked
we are going to navigate to this screen
here which is iphone 13 pro max 2 this
is the name here actually you can
actually it is advisable for you to
rename all of your screens that's the
best way to do it so this practically
means when the splash screen is clicked
on navigate to this other screen which
is this one here now we have an
animation section here that we can set
the animation of that transition or the
animation of that navigation so
currently it is set to instant
i can come here and set this to smart
animate then set this to ease in and out
and i'll set the animation delay time to
800 milliseconds just type in 800 there
and press the enter key on your keyboard
and figma will add the milliseconds for
you now this animation settings is
optional
the most important thing here is that we
have set the event and the action that
will be triggered by that event
then we have set the destination frame
for that action and that's okay so
that's sorted now i would come here
i would click on this button and i would
say okay when a user clicks on this
login button they should go to the login
screen which is this
now for the interaction details i'd
leave it set like this this is the
setting we had before now so i'll leave
it set like that now for the sign up
button when a user clicks on the sign up
button it means the user is a new user
so i would like that user to be taken to
the sign up page which is this one here
now when the user goes to the login page
and the user enters their email and
their password it means that they would
have to click on the login button and
when they click on
the login button i'd like them to go
straight to the home page which is this
now remember for a user to log in it
means the user is an existing user
now when a user
selects the sign up option here it means
the user is a new user and the user will
have to enter their email address phone
number and password right now when they
do that it means they would have to have
their phone number verified first so
when the user clicks on sign up the user
will be taken to
the verification code page
and when the user's phone number is
verified the user will then be taken to
the home page
and that's fine so you have seen that we
have created the authentication flow so
let's come over here
on the home page here let's work on the
next task now the next task is to fund
the account right
and to fund the account the user will
have to click on the fund account button
now when they do that we are going to
want a pop-up to show up on the screen
and that pop-up
should show this card here that will
that will require the user to choose the
method that they want to fund their
account with let's come here in our
interaction details over here it's an on
click event that's okay now over here we
have the navigate to option and that's
not what we want we want a pop-up to
show up on that same screen we don't
want the user to leave that page that
the user is on we want the user to still
stay on that page but have a popup show
up
so how do we make that happen we are
going to change this from navigate to to
openoverlay
when we change it to openoverlay we are
going to come here and select
the centered option because i would want
this popup to stay at the center of the
screen here so
over here i would keep this
selected which is closed when clicking
outside and i would also keep this add
background behind overlay option
selected then for the opacity of the
background overlay i would keep it set
to 25
now for the animation you can still keep
it set instant or come here and select
any other option of your choice so
that's okay and we are okay with that
now if a user selects bank transfer or
debit card they will be taken to another
page where they would have to process
that transaction method so you can also
come here if you don't mind let's click
on design you can come here and
duplicate this page
and
and create a low fidelity screen for
that you can call this bank transfer
and you can have whichever
element you want to have here and you
can go ahead to have the debit card page
also that the user will go to when they
select the debit card option here
but that's not the point here so i'll
take this out now we are done with
defund wallet task so the next task is
the invest task and this task will
happen from the home page it is when the
users go to the home page that they
would click on this invest option here
for them to go to the invest page so
that they can invest in stocks so from
this home page here i would come here i
would click on prototype from this
homepage here i would select this invest
button here and i would create a
connection to this page and that's okay
so when a user clicks on that invest
button at the navigation section there
on the home page
that user will be taken to this page
here which is the invest page where the
user will see
the list of stocks that they can invest
in and their stock portfolio
so if a user comes to this invest page
the task we want them to complete is to
invest
so let's say the user is cool with this
stock here and the user wishes to invest
in this talk i would select it then i
would create a connection like this this
means that when the user clicks on this
stock the user will go to the stock
details page for that stock and when the
user is okay with that stock details
that the user sees here the user will
click on the invest button here and the
user will go here to this other page
where the user will have to enter the
amount that they wish to invest in that
stocks with
and when the user enters the amount they
wish to invest with the user will click
on the next button which will take the
user to this page here where the user
will see a summary of the investment the
user is about to make and when the user
is okay with all the users is here the
user will click on proceed and the
investment which is the task will be
completed so what we have here is we are
done creating our low fidelity screens
and we can present our low fidelity
screens for testing now so how do we do
that i would come here i would select
the splash screen because that's where
the whole journey starts from right when
i select it i would come here and i
would click on this
present button here to have that
presented a new tab will be launched for
that
so i would come here
and i would click on the enter full
screen option here you can see where my
mouse cursor is on now this is
the presentation i would present to the
stakeholders which are my employers or
the owners of the app so i'll take this
presentation to them to demonstrate the
user experience that i have come up with
that will enable the users to accomplish
their tasks on this app so i'll go from
here i would click on this screen and
i'll explain to the stakeholders at this
point that
existing users can click on login and
new users can click on sign up so i
would demonstrate this as a new user i
would say okay when they click on sign
up they would come here enter their
email phone number and password
when they click on the signup button
they would have to enter a verification
code and when they are verified they
would go to the home page now if they
want to invest it means they have to
fund their account so i would click on
the fund account button to demonstrate
to them that in this case now we have a
bank transfer method and a debit card
method i would say okay if the users go
ahead to fund to fund the account then
it means the users are ready to invest
so for them to invest they would come
down here and click on the invest button
there when the user does that the user
will see list of stocks that they can
invest in and if the user chooses to
invest in any of the stock let's use
this for example they would click on it
when they click on it the user will be
taken to the stock details page for that
stock and when the user is satisfied
with the details of the stock the user
will click on the invest button here
then the user will be required to enter
the amount they wish to invest in that
stocks with when the user does that the
user will click on the next button here
and when the user clicks on that next
button
the user will see a summary of the
investment they are about to make and if
the user is satisfied the user clicks on
the proceed button here and the
investment will be successful
and when the user is done the user
clicks on back to home and the user will
be taken back to the home page so a
presentation like this
will really reveal the experience that
the user will have using this product so
if your low fidelity prototype has been
accepted by the stakeholders it means
that it is now time for you to go ahead
and start the process of designing
your high fidelity prototype which is
going to be like the real design version
of your app or the final design version
of your app and it is at that stage that
you would focus on things like colors
typography effects components library
style library and all of that so in this
course let's assume that our
stakeholders gave us a pass for these
low fidelity screens and they are okay
with it let's assume that our
stakeholders now want us to go ahead to
design the real version of the app
so what do we do let's click on design
come here create a new page
and call this
high fidelity
so at this stage i would like to welcome
everyone to the most interesting part
which is the part where we start
building our designs from scratch
so first things first i would go ahead
to create my style library and i would
start by creating my typography styles
so i'll do that using
the material design version 2 guide so i
would come over here i would go to
material.io
and when i come here i would click on
design when i click on design i would
come here on the left side and i would
click on typography then i would select
the type system and when i do that i
would come here so the first thing that
i would have set
is the typeface or font family that i
want to use for this project
for this project i would love to use
the rubik font family so i would come
here and i would select it here for
headlines and subtitles
then i would go ahead to select it here
for body and captions
just like that now i'll use the data
here in this type skill to create my
typography styles now let's start with
creating headline textiles for this
project now since this is a mobile app
project i won't see the need to have a
headline one text same for the headline
to text so i would go with the headline
for textile as my own headline one
textile just because this is a mobile
app design and this size of text is
going to look too big for a mobile app
so i would come here i would click on
headline for and i would use these
details here so i would come here i
would create a frame here where my
textiles are going to stay in so i would
say
headline one i'll duplicate this i would
say headline one bold so i would go out
say headline two now this is me getting
everything set before i start applying
the details that i would get here from
the type scale generator so i would come
here i would duplicate this and i would
say
headline two bold and
i'd come here i would have this here i
would say headline three
and
this is going to be headline three bold
and that's going to be that for my
headline textiles for this project now i
would go ahead to have my body textiles
so i would come here i would prepare
this for body large
and
i would have this be a body large bold
textile then i would go with but it's
small here and i would have this as body
small bold now this is my own style and
this is my own pattern i am not saying
this is the standard out there i'm just
doing this because this is what i feel
will give me the best design now come
here this will be for my button text and
i would have a caption text so after
having all of this set
i would come here i would select the
headline one text here and i would use
the headline for text style here in
material design just like i said i would
use this for my headline one textile so
the font family is set to rubik the
weight is set to normal which is regular
the size is set to 35 and the letter
spacing is set to 0.25 px so i would go
ahead and i would have all of this set
so i would come here keep this selected
i would set this to rubik and i would
set this to regular and for the letter
spacing i would come here and i would
set this to 0.25 px
and for the size i would set it to 35 px
now i would use these same settings for
this headline one text for the headline
one bold text the only difference will
be that this is going to be a bold text
and this is going to be a regular text
so i would select this now to set this
to 35 i would set this to rubik
and i'll keep it set to bold like i said
and i'll make this 0.25 px and that's
okay so i would go ahead and i'll do
same for headline 2 headline three body
large body large board down to the
caption text now for the headline two
text here i would come here in material
design and i would use the headline five
textile for my own headline to textile
so the font family is rubik the weight
is normal the size is 24 so i would set
the size to 24 and for the weight i
would keep it set to regular and for the
font family i would keep it set to rubik
now the letter spacing is 0px
so i can just keep it set at zero
percent or just come in here and type in
0px and that's fine i would use the same
setting for the headline to bold
but the difference will be that this is
going to be a bold text so i would come
here i would set this to 24 set this to
rubik
keep this set to zero keep the letter
spacing set to zero
and then keep this set bold so i can
have that
now for my headline three text if i come
here i would use
the headline six text style here for my
own headline three text so i would keep
this set to rubik this set to medium the
size set 20 so i'll keep the size set to
20 and for this i'll keep it set to
medium and i'll set this to rubik
then for the letter spacing it's set to
0.15 px so i would come here i would say
0.15 px and that's going to be cool
then for the headline 3 bold i would
have the same settings there but the
only difference as usual will be that
this is going to be a bold text so i
would come in here i would set this to
rubik
keep that set to bold
and for the size i think it's 20px and
for the letter spacing is 0.15
i'll type that in and i would keep this
set to 20 just like this
and that's okay so for the body large
text
come here and use the body one text
style here you can see that the size is
16 px the weight is normal and the
letter spacing is 0.5 px so i'd come
here i'd keep this here i would set
the letter spacing to 0.5 px
i would set the weight to regular and i
would set this to 16 and
i would set this to rubik and that's
okay for the body large board you know
what to do already i would set this to
16 set this to 0.5 px
set this to bold
then
set this to rubik
and that's it
so i would go ahead and i would have my
body small text here
and if i come here in material design i
would use the body to textile hair
material design for that so i'll keep it
set to normal set the size to 14 and
the letter spacing to 0.25 px
so i would have this set to 0.25 px i
would set this to 14. i would set this
to rubik and i would set this to regular
so i would have this here
and this is going to be 14 0.25
and
this is going to be rubik and that's
sorted now for the button text
i'll keep this here
if you come here you'll see that
the button text here has a size of 14 px
and a letter spacing value of 1.25 px
with a weight that is set to medium now
over here in material design 2 the
button text is all in upper case but in
my case i won't have my text stay in
uppercase and i think in material design
version 3 the button text is not
represented in uppercase so i would go
ahead and i would have this set to 14
and the letter spacing is pretty big so
i would have that
set to 1.25 px and
this will be set to medium with the font
family set to rubik and that's what we
have here
now for the caption text it's going to
be set to 12 px with a letter spacing
value of 0.4 px
and a normal weight so i would come here
i'll keep this here and i would have
this set regular
this will be 0.4 px
and this will be set to 12 just like
this
and
the font family will be set to rubik
so this is going to be a caption text so
at this stage what i'll do is i'll go
ahead to save all of these styles that i
have created to my style library and i
think we all know how to do that by now
so i would speed this process up i would
select this
come here and i would call this
headline one i would go ahead fast
forward this part of the course and come
back so this is it i have created and
saved the textile that i would need for
this project so i would come here and i
would rename this frame
typography styles just for better
documentation you know now when i click
on my empty canvas you would see that i
have all of my saved textiles over here
now let's go ahead and let's create our
color styles i would rename this frame
to color styles i'd save that now i
would create my color styles based on my
need i want to make use of the material
design guide to create my color styles
and that's because you can actually do
that you can create your color styles
your textiles you can create any of your
styles without using the material design
guide and you can actually mix it you
can create your textiles with the
material design guide and have your
color styles created from your own
inspiration so i would come here i'd
like to have a background color here
so i would use this for my background
color i'd have a text stay at the top
here to indicate that this is for my
background color i would select this
text and i would make use of one of my
saved textiles so i'll go with the body
large text there so for my background
color style i would like to use this
color and that's good let's zoom into
this point so we can see clearly and
after having a background color i'll
duplicate this use this hair i would
love to have a surface color and for my
surface color i would like it to be this
color here you can use any color of your
choice this is my own choice so i'll
duplicate this i'd have this stay here
and this time i would like to have a
surface text color you can call this an
unsurface color actually so i would like
to have a surface text color which is
going to be the color that i would use
to write text on the surface color so i
like this to be white actually i know
this may not be visible but i'd like
that to be white just like that
so i would duplicate this
now for us to make this visible i would
select it and i'll add a shadow effect
the next color that i'd have here we
called the off text color and that's my
own choice i'd like to have another
color for my text so i would use this
shade for my off text color and i'll
duplicate this and i'll have another
color here which is going to be my error
color and obviously this is going to be
a red color so i would use this shade of
red for that then i would have this here
and i would like to have a second
surface color and i would like that
color to be just like this and that's
fine so i have selected all of the color
styles that i would want for this
project so i would go ahead and i would
save all of these styles to my style
library and i think we all know how to
do that so i would select this come here
and i'll call that background color i
would speed up this process and i'll
come back to it so as you can see i am
done creating and saving my color styles
and these are my color styles here so
that's sorted the next thing i'd like us
to do is to go ahead and create the grid
style that we are going to use for this
project so to do that i would use a
mobile layout i would use the iphone 13
pro max layout so i would have the
iphone 13 pro max layout here i would
rename it to mobile
grid style i would zoom in to this point
i would keep it selected then i would
add a layout grid property to it just
like that then i would have this
be a column grid
and i would have the count before i
would have the margin b16 i would have
the gutter b16 and
for the color i would go with something
like this
now
we are sorted for the column grid so i
would go ahead and i would add a row
grid property to it i'll keep it
selected still come here and i'll add
another grid property that i would set
as a row grid property just like this i
would set the count to 800 and i would
set the stretch to center i would set
the gutter property to zero i would come
here i would set the height property to
eight and that's because i want this
space between the row lines to be hpx
then i would come here and i'll change
the color to something like this and
that's going to be okay for me so i
would keep this selected come here and i
would save this grid style as my grid
style for this project so i would click
on style there and i would call this
mobile grid style you can call it
whatever you want to call it now we have
three styles saved to our style library
we have our textiles we have our color
styles and we have our grid styles so i
would like for us to go ahead and create
shadow styles for this project
so to do that i would come here i would
have a frame here
then i would
rename this to shadow styles when i
renamed that to shadow styles i would
have some rectangles right inside that
frame and
the rectangle is just to display the
shadow effect and how it's going to look
like so i'll keep that selected i would
make the color reduce to have a value of
8
i would give it
this color and i'll duplicate this and
i'll have this here i'll just have three
shadow effect styles so i'll keep that
there and i would come here in material
design and i would go to the home page i
would click on the search icon there and
i'll type in shadow when i press the
enter key i would have these results
show up so i would come here i would
click on this link here that's going to
take me to material design version 1
where i would make use of the
recommendations that they have there for
creating shadow styles so i would click
on that link now come here and i would
use this shadow recommendations that's
under the sketch section so i won't go
with the one dp elevation table here i
would scroll down and i would make use
of this 16 dp elevation table so i would
use these values here to create my
shadow styles so i would create a key
shadow and an ambient shadow now under
the key shadow you can see that we have
two types of key shadow styles we have
the umbra key shadow style and the
penumbra key shadow style so i would
create an umbra key shadow style first
and for that the opacity value is set to
14. so i would come here i would keep
this selected i would add an effect
property and i would set the opacity
value here to 14 and the x property is
set to zero with the y property set to
16. so i would come here for the y
property i would set this to 16. the x
property here is already set to zero now
the blow property is 24 and the spread
property is two so for the blow property
i would set it to 24 and for the spread
property i would set it to and here we
have our umbra key shadow effect so i
would go ahead and i would create for
the penumbra key shadow effect and the
ambient shadow effect so i would speed
up this process also and i would come
back when i'm done so these are the
shadow styles that i have created so i
would go ahead and i would save them to
my style library the way to do that is
pretty easy select this rectangle there
then come here in the effects section
click on that style icon there and you
can call this whatever you want to call
it i would call this light shadow i
would call this other one here mid
shadow and i would call this pick shadow
and that's okay so far i have my
textiles created i have my color styles
created i have my effect styles created
and i have my grid styles created now at
this stage we are ready to start
designing the component or app so i
would like us to go ahead and start that
so the method i would like to use in the
designing of our component
will go like this i would like for us to
design a component based on the user
task of this app now the first task i'd
like us to look at is the authentication
task so for this task i'd like us to
design all of the components that will
be needed to complete this task so let's
come up here let's have a text here i
would zoom in to 200 and i would have a
text here this is going to be the
section where i would have all of my
authentication component so i would come
here i would select this textile to have
that there so for the authentication
task we have the login form and the sign
up form so for the login form which
components do we have there we have the
input field and we have the button so i
would go ahead to design the input field
so i would come here i would just say
input now this is going to be my
placeholder so i would come here and i
would use the body small text for that
and i would keep it selected then create
an auto layout on it now when i create
an auto layout on it i'll add a fill
color like this then i would just
stretch it to this point now i would
still keep this auto layout selected
come here and make sure that the content
of the auto layout is aligned to the
left and that's fine now for the corner
reduce property i would give it a corner
reduce value of 8 to have that now i'd
come here and i would
rename this to impute field now while
this is here i would select the
background color for the input field
itself then the text here i would give
it this off text color here and i like
this input field to have a stroke color
which is going to be the color of the of
text also so i can have this now this is
sorted we are done with creating an
input field this input field is what we
are going to use for the collection of
emails passwords phone numbers so i
would go ahead keep it selected and i
would come here and i'll click on create
component now the next thing to create
will be our button component so i would
come here and i would have this text
here and
for that text i would come here and i
would select the button text for that
now i'll keep the text selected and i
would create an auto layout on the text
now i would come here or the button auto
layout i would make sure the padding
around items value is set to 16. now
same happened for this the padding
around items value for this input field
is also 16 so take note of that now for
this button component i would come here
and i'll give it this color which is the
surface color now for the text there i
would come here and i would give it the
surface text color which is white now i
would come here i would select the
button auto layout come here and i'll
align the content of that auto layout to
stay at the center still keep it
selected come here and give it a corner
reduce of 8 and there we have a button
component created so i would come here i
would rename this to button then come
here and click on create component and
there we have created a button component
now the next component i would like for
us to create here under the
authentication task
will be the input field that the users
will have to impute their verification
code in now that input field will not
look like this it's going to look
different so i'd like for us to go ahead
and do that so i would come here i would
have a text here let's just say zero and
i'll keep that number selected then go
ahead and create an auto layout on that
number now i'll keep the auto layout i
just created selected come here and i'll
align the content of the auto layout to
stay at the center of the auto layout
then i would come here and i would add
the fill color to that auto layout now
i'd come here i would select the pen
tool and i'll just draw a line
horizontally then i'd click on done and
this line i just created here will be
grabbed and taken into that auto layout
that has that number zero and you can
see that that line is placed here now
what i'll do is this i would come here
inside this auto layout now i would
select this straight line that i created
which is called vector one here when i
select it i would come here and i'll
change its horizontal resizing value
from fixed width to fill container so
that i can have that now i have a
problem here the padding around value
for this auto layout is really big so i
would select the auto layout i would
come here and i would set it to eight
when i set it to eight it's going to
look like this now i'd like it to be
like this because if i am placing this
component on my screen i would most
likely
increase the width and as you can see
when i increase the width the number
zero just stays the way it is but the
line itself stretches across the
container which is actually what i want
so this is okay now now since the
verification code will be a four digit
verification code i'd like to have this
component go into four places i'll go
ahead and i'll do that so i'll keep this
component selected and i would create
another auto layout on top of it like
this now this auto layout that i just
created is called frame two i would keep
it selected come here and now it sets
its direction property to horizontal
direction when i set that to horizontal
direction i would come here and i would
set the padding around items value to
zero just like that now i would come
here and i would expand the frame to
auto layout now just so that i can
access the frame one auto layout inside
of it now when i select that frame one
auto layout inside of it i'll duplicate
it and you can see that i have
duplicated this into four places now i
would come back here i would select the
frame to auto layout and i would set the
spacing between items value to zero just
to have this now let's check to see if
this auto layout itself is a responsive
auto layout so i'll keep it selected
still and i would come here and i'll try
to expand it and as you can see if i
expand it horizontally the
layout itself is not responding to that
expansion so i would ctrl z to go back
to how we were before and at this stage
what i'm going to do is this i would
select the individual sub auto layout
inside this main auto layout i would
select this one which is frame 1 i would
come here and i would set its horizontal
resizing value to fill container and
i'll do that for all of them just like
that now when i select the frame to auto
layout now and i increase the size
horizontally you'll see that it's all
responsive
and that's what i want so i'll keep this
here i would rename this to verification
impute keep it selected come here and
click on create component and that's
sorted so at this stage i'd like for us
to go ahead and create our
authentication screens so let's create a
section for that not a page actually i
would say authentication screens
authentication hi-fi screens just like
this so i would come here i would have
an iphone 13 pro mark screen here and i
would rename this make sure you rename
your layout at this stage so i would
rename this to splash and we all know
what the splash screen is yeah that's
the screen you see when you launch an
app so i would come here i'll change the
color of the splash screen to this and
on the splash screen i'd like for us to
have the logo of the brand and the logo
of this brand is really easy it's just v
x s t just like that so i would keep the
text selected i would come here and i
would go with the headline to bold and
i'll work with this so i would keep that
text selected come here and align it
horizontally and align it vertically
and that's okay so this is a splash
screen so after the splash screen the
next screen to create will be the screen
where the user will have to select the
authentication action so i'll duplicate
this splash screen i'll take this out
and i'll change the color of this screen
now to this then come here and rename it
auth selection you can call it whatever
you want to call it now over here i
would bring in the button component i
would go to my asset panel i'll bring
this in and i would align it to the
center horizontally and i would expand
it to this point now for me to expand it
properly i would need to apply my grid
style on this layout so i would come
here and i would apply my mobile grid
style here so that i can use this as my
guide to properly expand this button so
i'd like the button to take up two
column grids and that's what i have here
so i would come here i'll change the
text to login and i would bring in
another button component here and i'll
change this to get started now i'd come
here select this button component and
change its color to this just to make it
different so i would keep this here and
i'll keep this here and that's fine so i
would select this and i'll align it to
the center vertically and i'll bring
this and i'll place this get started
button right under this login button but
i'll use the row grid so i set in the
space value i would give to that so i
have one two three four rows here and
it's into four places is 32 so i have a
32 px bottom margin space between this
login button and the get started button
now i think the raw grid is not really
visible so i would come here i would go
to my auto grid saved style i would
click on edit style i would select rows
and i would increase the opacity of that
color to 20. so this is sorted this
screen is sorted now if the user goes
ahead to click on the login button here
it means the user will go to the login
page right so i would create that now so
let's zoom in let's take this out
and let's click on layers and change the
name of this frame to login page and
what i'll do is this when i zoom in i'll
bring this here so what i'll do is i'll
just have logo stay here i would come
here and i would select headline to bold
that's too big i would go with headline
three bold that's okay so i would align
it to stay at the center horizontally
and i'll bring it down to this point
then i'll change the color to this now
what i'll do next is to have my login
form created and i'll do that with my
input field here which is this now i'd
like this input field to stretch from
here to here just like that
now this input field would have a label
here so i'll just give it a label here
that says enter email address
i'll keep label here now the space
between this label and this input field
is 16px i have two row spaces between
this label text and this input field now
for the input field i'll change the
placeholder text from input to enter
email address that's okay so i would
come here i would have another input
field here which is going to be used for
the password so i would change the
placeholder here to enter password and
i'll give this input field its own label
i'll duplicate this and first of all i
would say okay the space between this
input field and this label text should
be one two three four five six
eight times six is 48 so i would like a
48 px margin space between this input
field and this label text so that's
sorted now i'd like a 16 px space
between this label text and
this input field so i would come here
and i would edit this
from enter email address to enter
password that's okay let's align this
properly so the next thing i would have
here is the login button so i'll bring a
button component here and for this
button component i'd like to have a
margin space here of 32px so it's going
to be one two three four so i'll bring
this here place this there and let's
zoom out let's stretch this to this
point and stretch this to this point
then i'll change the text of the button
to login let's see how it looks
okay this doesn't look really good the
spacing is not really consistent so i
would zoom out
and i'd have the space between this
label text and this input field to be
32px actually so it's going to be one
two three four so i would have that
stayed there and i would have this stay
here then i would have one two three
four five six which is 48 px so let's
see how it looks so this looks okay
now i'd like us to have a text here
which is going to be the forgot password
text forgot password so let's keep this
here and let's have that stay
16 px away from this input field and 16
px away from this button component so i
would select the text and i'll make sure
it is a body small text and that's okay
so i'll zoom out you can see that we
have that
so i would go ahead and i would create
the sign up page for our authentication
task so i would come here i would click
on layers and i would rename this to
sign up page and if you come here the
only difference we are going to have
here is the fact that we are going to
have an additional input field to
collect the user's phone number so this
means that i'll take this out for now
take this out for now and i would have
another placeholder here which is going
to have a margin top space of 32px which
is one two three four i'll bring this
here
and i would bring in an input field
which is going to stay here
then i'll
stretch the input field to this point
now i'll use this
second input field to collect the user's
phone number and i'll change the
placeholder here to phone number then i
would use this third input field to
collect the user's password just like
that now i'll go ahead and i'll bring in
a button here and this button is going
to have a 48 px margin top space it's
going to be one two three four five six
i'll bring this here and i'll change the
text here to sign up so i would zoom out
i would keep this selected i would
stretch this to this point and i would
stretch this to this point and that's
sorted so we have created a login screen
and a sign up screen now when the users
click on the sign up button here the
users will be taken to that page where
they would have to enter the
verification code that was sent to their
phone number so we are going to go ahead
to create that page so i would come here
and i would rename this verification
page and i'll take all of this out over
here after the logo i would have a
rectangle that's going to be
that's going to be this big i like the
rectangle to be a 48 px tall rectangle
just like this i'll zoom out i'd have
this here and i'll stretch the rectangle
to this point and i would have the
rectangle have this background color now
on this rectangle i would have a text
that says
a verification code has been
sent to just like that so i'll keep this
text here and i'll use a body small text
for that then i'll align the text to the
center horizontally then i'll keep this
text aligned to the horizontal center of
the page just to stay like this and
that's okay and that's okay so i'll go
ahead and i'll bring in that input
components for the verification code but
before i do that let's change the color
of this text so i would come here and
i'll give you this color then i would
click on the asset panel now and i'll
bring in this
component now for this component i'll
keep it selected first things first i'll
change the color of that component i
would select the individual items inside
the component and i'll change this to
the background color that we have just
like this and that's okay now for the
lines that we have i'll change the color
of all those lines to this
and for the numbers i'll change the
color of the numbers to this and that's
okay so i would keep this selected i
would increase
the width to this point so let's zoom in
so that we can organize this properly so
i would keep this here and i would snap
the height at this point
just like this
so i would have a placeholder text there
that's going to say enter verification
code just like this and i'll change the
color of that text to this so let's go
ahead and let's change the color of this
label text that we have here to this
change this
to this come here change this
to this and change this to this now for
the enter password text here i'll change
it to this also and for the forgot
password text
i'll change it to this and that's okay
now let's go back to our verification
code page and let's
have this button come up to this point
so it's going to be one two three four
five six i'll keep this here and i'll
just have a verified text there just
like that so at this stage
we have created a verification page for
our authentication task now when the
users click on the verify button we are
going to need a pop-up that would show
up on the screen to let the users know
that their verification has been
successful now how do we create that
popup it's simple i would come here i
would select the frame tool now it
creates a pop-up just like this now the
reason i'm creating this here is so that
i can use the width of this layout to
set the width of this pop-up now the
definite way to do this is this if you
come here and you select this page you
would see that the width is
428
now the margin space on this layout is
16 here and 16 here which is 32 right so
to get the container space here and use
the width of the container space for
this my pop-up would be me subtracting
32 from
428 so i'll just select this outcome
here i would say four to eight minus 32
and that's going to be the width for my
pop-up and this is it as easy as that so
i would come here and i would give it a
corner reduce of it then i would go
ahead and i would give it this
background color when i give it this
background color then i would have a
text right inside that layout that's
going to say phone number verified or
whatever you want to say
so i would come here and i would select
a better text style for that i would go
with the body large textile just like
this i would align it to the center
horizontally now i would bring in the
button component here and i would have a
proceed button here that the user will
click on to go to the home page and we
are done creating this so i would select
this go to the layers tab and i would
call this verify pop-up just like that
so that popup is going to show up when
the user enters their verification code
here and
click on the verify button so i would
grab this now and i'll place it here and
that's fine so at this stage i would
like to say that we are done with
creating all of the screens that we need
for our authentication task
so this is going to take us to the next
task of our app and that task is
actually the fund task
where the users will have to fund their
wallet or their accounts so that they
can invest so i would come here and i
would have this here i'll change this to
fund account so all of the components
that i would have here will be the
components that will aid the user to
fund their accounts on this app so let's
go ahead and let's do that now what you
need to take note of is this for a user
to fund the account the user will have
to go to the home page of the app first
right because it is from the home page
that they would see the fund account
button so what does this mean this means
that we need to create components for
the home page and have our home page
sorted first before we handle the fund
account route so let's go ahead and
let's do that
on the home page the first component
that we are going to have will be a card
component that will display the balance
that we have in our account and it is
still on that card component that we are
going to have the fund account button so
let's go ahead and let's create that so
i would have a text here it's going to
say primary account i would keep that
text selected and i would set the
typography style to
body small board now let's zoom into 200
so this is it now i would come here and
i would create another text which is
going to be like the account number or
the account id so i would say this and i
would keep that selected also now i
would set this to body small so now i
would select both of these and i would
create an auto layout on the both of
them now when that auto layout is
created i would make sure that the
padding around items value is set to
zero for now now outcome here i would
select this text and i would set its
horizontal resizing value to fill
container i would select this here and i
would set its horizontal resizing value
to fill container and for the height i
would come here and i would set the
height property here to auto height to
make it balanced now we have this
created so i would come here i'll add a
fill color to this now i'll duplicate
this i'll bring this here and i'll
change this text to account balance or
let's just say available balance
actually let's not say account balance i
would say available balance and here
i'll write down the available balance
that's fine so i'll keep this here also
now what i'll do is i would select these
two auto layouts and i would add an auto
layout on the both of them for this new
auto layout that i have created i would
come here and i would set the spacing
between items value to 24 and i would
select this auto layout that's inside
this new auto layout and i would set its
horizontal resizing value to fill
container and i'll do that for this also
now i would select this new auto layout
and i'll add a fill color of white to it
to have this now you can see that this
is actually responsive
and that's okay now i'd like to bring in
a button component and place it inside
this auto layout so that that button
will be used for the fund account action
so i would come here i would bring in a
button component here then i would
select that button component in the in
the design three here hold it and grab
it into this frame seven auto layout
which is our auto layout and you can see
that the button component is placed
inside this auto layout now i would like
this button component to look different
so i would keep it selected come here
and i would set its top padding value to
it and its bottom padding value to eight
so i can have this now i'll change this
text
to fund account
just like this and that's okay now i'll
go to the feather icons plugin and i'll
look for an icon that outplays on the
right side to make that component just
look better let's come in here let's
just type in home i'll bring this in
actually i'll bring this here and i'll
place it here now i would select all of
these and i would create an auto layout
on all of them now a new auto layout
called frame 8 has been created now
inside this frame it auto layout we have
this auto layout here and this icon so i
would select this auto layout now that's
inside the frame 8 auto layout and i
would set the value for its horizontal
resizing property to fill container and
i'll leave this set to fixed wii now i
would select the frame it auto layout
now which is our main auto layout now
and i would come here and i would set
the spacing between items value to 24.
when i do that i would come here and i
would add a fill color to this and i
would add the fill color to the auto
layout to have this and the final thing
i'll do here is to come here and set
the padding around items value to 16.
when that's done i'll give it a corner
reduce of 8 to have this now i can
expand this to this point like this and
you can see that this component is
responsive and that's that so let's go
ahead and let's play around with the
colors of the elements on this component
so i would select this
text here and i'll give it this color i
would select this and i'll give it this
color do same for this and do same for
this
then for this
i would select the icon itself and
that's fine so i would rename this to
balance card or whatever you want to
call it i would keep it selected and
i'll click on create component and here
we have a component created so on the
home page still i'd like to display a
list of recent transactions that's been
carried out on the app so let's go ahead
and let's create a component that's
going to serve that purpose so i would
come here i would create a text
i would call that deposit come here and
i would select the body large bold text
then i would come here and i would
create another text and i would have
this which is going to be a date that
the deposit happened so i would select
these two text and i would create an
auto layout on the both of them now i
would select this text inside the auto
layout and outset its horizontal
resizing value to fill container and
i'll do that for this also now i'll
select the auto layout and i'll set its
spacing between items value to 4 and
that's okay now for this deposit text
i'll change the color to this and for
the date here i'll change its color to
this and that's okay so i'll keep this
here and the next thing i'll do is to
have a frame here that's going to be
48 by 48
i'll keep it selected and i'll give it a
corner reduce of 100 to make it round
then i'll go to the feather icons plugin
and i would have an icon there that
signifies incoming which is this i would
select this icon now and i'll place it
on top of this 48
by 48 px frame that i created when i
place it there i would come here and i
would set its constraint value to center
for the horizontal axis and center for
the vertical axis and that's okay now i
would select this frame which is now a
circle and i would set its color let's
set it to green like this and for the
icon i would set its color to this
and that's okay now for this frame now
that i have created i'll bring it and
i'll place it here and i'll select all
of this and i would create an auto
layout on the both of them now for this
new auto layout i would come here and i
would set its spacing between items
value to 16 and i would come here and i
would set its alignment value to the
center just like this now i would keep
it selected still come here and add a
fill color to it just like this now i
would come here now and i would create
this text and this text is going to be a
body large bold text now i would come
here and i would create another text
which is going to just like display the
balance i would keep that selected and i
would make it a caption text just like
this now i would select both of them
create an auto layout on the both of
them and set the spacing between items
value to four now i'll select the text
inside the auto layout now and i'll set
its horizontal resizing value to fill
container to have that
and that's sorted so i would select this
now and i'll give it a fill color of
white now for the color of the text i
would set this to something light like
this and this will be
something like that now what i'll do is
i would select all of these and i would
create an auto layout on all of them
first things first i would align the
content of the auto layout to stay at
the center then i would add a fill color
to the auto layout to have this now for
the spacing between items value of this
new auto layout now i like to set it to
76 and that's okay now for the padding
around items value i'd like to set this
to 8 and that's okay now let's check to
see if this auto layout is responsive as
you can see it's not so let's sort that
out and to sort it out is really easy i
would select this frame here this auto
layout here i would select this auto
layout here and i would set its
horizontal resizing value to fill
container now when i set this to fill
container i would select the auto layout
that's inside it which is frame 8 and i
would set its horizontal resizing value
to fill container also now i'll make
sure all of this is set to fill
container so i would select the items to
be sure that they are also set to fill
container
now when i select the frame 12 now which
is a major frame
you would see that
this is now responsive
and that's okay so i'll keep it selected
come here and i would set the corner
reduce value to it and i have this
i'd like to duplicate this to have a
withdrawal component where this circle
is going to be read and the icon is
going to be different so i'll set the
position of this icon
to let's set it to 180
that's the angle position that's what i
am setting here or you can call it the
rotation property of that icon so i'm
setting it to 108
degrees
and i'll change this with drawer
then you can change all of these details
if you want to change them i would
select the circle itself which is this
frame and i'll change the color to this
and that's okay so i would come here i
would select this i would rename this to
withdrawal card keep it selected make it
a component okay that's supposed to be
deposit card so i would select this come
here and i would rename this to deposit
card keep it selected come here and
click on create component then select
this rename this to withdrawal card keep
it selected and make it a component and
that's sorted still on the homepage we
are going to have a banner that will be
used to copy referral links so i would
go ahead and out create that so i would
have this text here that's going to say
invite
your friends i'll keep that selected and
i would go with this
textile here which is the body large
bold textile and i would have another
text here that's going to be
invite your friends with the spark code
and i'll go with the caption textile
here and that's cool so i would select
this when i select it i would create an
auto layout and i would come here i
would set the spacing between items
value to eight then i would select the
text items inside this auto layout and i
would set this to fill container and
i'll do that for this also now the next
thing i would like to do is to have a
frame layout here that's going to be 48
by 48 and i would keep it selected still
i would give it a corner reduce value of
100 then come here and give it that
color now i would go over to the feather
icons plugin and i'd look one and i
would look for an icon i can use on that
so i like to use this icon here i would
select it i'll bring it here and place
it on this frame layout now when i place
it there i would make sure it's at the
center then i would come here and i
would set its horizontal constraint
value to center and its vertical
constraint value to center and that's
okay now i would select that icon then i
would set its color to this and that's
okay now i would select all of this
create an auto layout on it so i would
come here and i would align the content
of that auto layout to always stay at
the center now i'll keep this auto
layout selected and i'll give it a fill
color which is going to be the
background color like this
now i would select this auto layout that
is inside this main auto layout now as
you can see it's the frame 12 auto
layout that has this text when i select
it i would come here and i would set
this to fill container and when i select
the main auto layout now you'd see that
this is a responsive auto layout which
means we are good to go now for the
spacing between items value of this auto
layout i'd like to set it to 24 and for
the padding around items value i like to
set it to 16 to have that then come here
and set the corner reduce value to it
and here we have our component so i
would keep this selected now rename this
to referral banner then come here and
click on create component to make it a
component and that's okay now on our
home page we have one final component
which is going to be a very interesting
component to create and that's going to
be the navigation component on our home
page which is going to be at the bottom
so let's see how we can create that
component before we put our homepage
screen together so i would come here and
i would get the home icon from the
feather icons plugin
i'll type in home there i'll bring this
in now i like to zoom in at this point
so that you can see clearly when i place
this icon here i would come here and i
would create a text and i'll call that
home now for this home text i would
create an auto layout on it and i would
set the padding around items value for
that auto layout zero then set its
alignment position to the center now i
would select the home text that is
inside this auto layout and i would set
its horizontal resizing value to fill
container now i would keep this text
auto layout here then i would select the
home icon and that text auto layout and
i would create an auto layout on the
both of them now this auto layout is
frame 15. what i'll do now is i would
come here and i would set the spacing
between items value for this auto layout
so 4. when i do that i would come here
and i would set the alignment of the
content in that auto layout to always be
at the center now i would come here and
i would select the home auto layout and
i would set its horizontal and resizing
value to fill container and that's okay
just stretch this and it's going to be
sorted
now at this stage what i'll do is this
i would have a frame layout here that's
going to be 48 by 48 and i would grab
this frame 15 auto layout now and i'll
place it on this 48 by 48 px frame
layout make sure it's at the center when
i place it at the center i would select
the frame 16 frame layout which is our
48 by 48 layout now and i would make it
an auto layout now when i make it an
auto layout i'll bring it here and i
would rename this to home link now after
i rename it to homelink i would come
here and i would set its alignment to
the center so that the content of that
auto layout will always be at the center
now the padding top value is set to 3 i
would set it to 4 just so that we are
going to have even numbers all around i
would set this to four also
and this outset to four and this outset
to four just to have this so at this
stage what i'd like to do now is to have
other navigation links so i would keep
this home link auto layout selected and
i would create another auto layout on
top of it now this auto layout that i
just created has a padding around items
value of 16 yeah i'll leave it set to 16
because actually that's what it's
supposed to be now i would come here i
would expand this new auto layout and i
would select the home link auto layout
and i'll duplicate it like this into
three places and that's because i want
to have just three items there now i
would come here i'll change this from
home to invest and i'll change this from
home
to transact let's select our frame 16
and let's add a fill color to it to have
this so if i expand the frame 16 you'd
see that the icon and the text is just
there it's not responsive so i'd like to
change that so to change that i would
select this home link set this to fill
container select this do that also
select this and do that also now when i
select frame 16 and i increase the width
horizontally you would see that this
text wrapping to the next line is
actually fixed so for these icons let's
go ahead and let's change this icon to a
better icon and this to a better icon so
i would come here i would go to the
feather icons plugin and i would like to
have this icon so i'll bring this here
and i would come in here and i'll trace
the auto layout that has that you can
see it's still called home link i'll
change that to invest link when i change
it to invest link you'll see that we
have the the home icon inside here so i
would come here now i would select this
bar chart icon now and i'll take it
inside the invest link auto layout now
place it right inside here and you can
see that it is here at the bottom so i
would select the home icon and i would
delete it with the delete key on my
keyboard then come here grab this invest
icon hold it and take it upwards like
this so i would go ahead and i'll do
same for the transact link here so i
would keep this selected come here i
would
rename this to bottom navigation keep it
selected and click on create component
and that component has been created so
at this stage we can go ahead to make
use of all of these components in
designing our home page so to design our
home page i would come here i would
select the frame tool and i'll bring in
an iphone 13 pro max frame here and i'll
zoom in to this point now i would select
this iphone 13 pro max frame rename this
to home when i do that i would come here
and i would apply the grid style on it
and when i do that let's zoom into 200 i
would go ahead and
i would bring in the menu icon using the
feather icons plugin so i'll use that
one there now whenever you bring in an
icon and you want to place it into a
layout make sure the icon is inside that
layout here in the design tree as you
can see currently this icon which is
aligned justify is not placed inside
this layout which is our home page so
what i'll do is i would come here in the
design tree click on it to select it
hold it and drag it into the home layout
and as you can see it is now inside the
home layout so i would come here and
i'll place this here so i would count it
rows pieces from the top one two three
four five six seven and eight and that's
okay so i would have a text here so i
can come here and i can say hi and for
la cair now i would like to call your
attention
to something important and that is the
fact that as you can see here i have the
name of the user written here which is
anne folake now the question you should
ask is this how did i arrive at
displaying the name of the user here
when in the sign up form i did not
collect the name of the user if you
remember in my sign up form i only
collected the email address the phone
number and the password of the user
which means that the app itself does not
have a record of the name of the user so
the question you'd ask which is normal
is how did i arrive at displaying the
name of the user here
now this is going to be your first
assignment in this course because i'd
like you to come here in the
authentication section here and refactor
the authentication flow here to collect
the name of any user that's signing up
to this app now i'll leave this open
without giving you a guide on how to do
that i would like to see your thoughts
process on how to refactor this
authentication process with the best
experience and also with the fact that
you would collect the name of any user
signing up to this application if you
think coming here and adding another
field for the name collection is fine go
ahead and do that if you have another
idea that can make the experience better
go ahead and implement that now when you
implement the name collection in the
authentication task here go ahead tag me
on social media for my comment that's
your first assignment in this course
then i can have another text here i'll
bring this here
now the next thing i would like to have
here is the balance card so i would come
here in the assets panel and i'll bring
this component in like this now i'd like
to have four row spaces between this
text and the balance card but before i
do that i'd like to keep this balance
card selected then come here and apply
my shadow style that i saved to it so i
would go with the mid shadow like this
now let's zoom into this point and let's
make sure we have four row spaces and
that's okay
let's zoom out now what we are going to
do is to stretch this to this point and
that's going to be successful because
our component is a responsive component
so nothing is going to break and this is
okay so i would come here at the bottom
here i would snap this to this row line
and that's sorted so the next thing i'm
going to have here is a text that's
going to say recent transactions i'll
keep that selected and i would go with a
body large bold text so i'll make sure i
have one two three four gross pieces
there and that's sorted so i would have
that there and i would select a
different color for that i would go with
this now for this also i would have this
color set to this now just in case i
forget to set the color of a text as i
proceed you go ahead and do that so i
would select this icon also and i'll
change the color to this and that's okay
now right under this will be sent
transactions text i would have those
transaction cards there so i'll bring
this in which is the deposit card i
would give it a shadow style i would
come here i would give it a mid shadow
style there let's zoom out to this point
and i'll stretch this to this end here
and i'll make sure this snaps properly
too and that's not going to be a problem
because our component is responsive so
let's look at the spacing between this
card and this text i'll zoom in you can
see we have one two three i'll make this
four and let's zoom out okay that's
actually too
far away
so i'll bring this here i would have two
row spaces okay so i would have this one
here so i would have two row spaces from
this text to this card and if i select
the text you'd see that i have one row
space here and two row space before this
card and that's okay so what i'll do now
is i'll go ahead i'll duplicate this and
when i duplicate it i'll make sure i
have just one row space which is 8px i
would bring in this other one which is
for which is for a withdrawal event i
would come here i'd give it a mid shadow
i'll zoom out and i would snap this to
this point and i would make sure it's
just
8 px space so i'll bring this here and
that's okay
now i'll have just three recent
transactions here so i'll go ahead and
bring in this referral banner and i
place it here so i'll make this snap to
the end also to stay at that point and
i'll zoom in and i'll make sure i have a
consistent space in here so i would have
a 48 px margin space over here which is
going to be six row spaces right so i
would have one two three four five six
so i'll bring this and i'll place it
here so i'll zoom out and at this point
what i'll bring in will be a bottom
navigation component i'll bring it and
i'll place it here let's zoom in and
let's make sure this is properly placed
as you can see i have properly placed
this so i would keep it selected come
here and i'll change the fill color to
this i would select this change the fill
color to this
select this select this i'll change the
fill color to this now i'll select the
icon itself and i'll change the fill
color to this i'll do that for this also
and i'll do that for this also now for
the text i would select the text and
i'll change the fill color to this
and that's okay now for the text color
of this navigation link i'd like the
text color actually to be pure white so
that it can be really present there
and i think this is better and that's it
so we have just designed our home page
now using the components that we created
so i would also advise that while
designing it's also good most times to
test what you are designing so i would
select this come here and i would click
on present to see how this is going to
look like actually so this doesn't look
good like this i like to present this
inside an iphone device so i would come
here click on prototype click on
prototype settings and i'll select a
device here which is iphone 13 pro max
when i do that i would come here i would
select this layout once more and i would
click on present again that's going to
sort it
and this is what we have this looks good
you can come here and present this in
full screen just like this to see it
better so let's go ahead and let's keep
designing our application so i would
press the escape key on my keyboard to
go out of that full screen display and
i'll come back here
so the next action i'd like to design
for will be the action of the user
clicking on the font account button so
when the user clicks on the font account
button i would like to display a pop-up
that will allow the user choose the
method in which they would like to fund
the account with and that's easy because
we have actually created a pop-up before
so i would come here i'll duplicate this
pop-up and i'll have the pop-up stay
here and right inside this pop-up here i
would have one button here which is
going to say bank transfer and i would
have another button here that's going to
present the option to fund the account
with a debit card so i would have this
day here and i would expand this to this
point and i'll expand this to this point
i'll also keep this here i'd expand this
to this point i'll expand this to this
point i'll keep it selected and i would
center it horizontally so i would come
here i would bring this downwards
and i'd have a text here that's going to
say select method
so i'll change the color of that text to
this and that's going to be cool so i
would select this pop-up now and i would
rename it from verify popup to pond
method
pop-up i'd keep it selected and i would
make it a component and that's going to
be it so when the users click on fund
account here they would have this popup
show up asking them to choose the method
in which they would like to fund their
account with now let's say they select
the bank transfer method they will be
taken to the page where they would have
that happen so for that i would create
that page now so i would come here i'll
duplicate this and i would rename it
bank transfer when i rename it to bank
transfer i would come here and i'll take
all of these out
and i would also take the bottom
navigation out also so what i would have
here is an icon that will direct the
users back to the previous page so i
would go to feather icons when i come
here i would scroll down and i would
select this icon for that so i'll take
this out and i'll bring this here and as
you can see this icon is not inside this
layout that's why this smart guide is
not active so i would come here i would
select this icon and i'll take it into
this layout
just like this now when i select it and
i move it around you would see that the
smart guide is active so i'll make sure
that i have eight spaces from the top
one two three four five six seven eight
and that's correct so i would keep that
icon select and i'll change the color of
the icon vector to this and that's okay
the next thing i'll have here is a title
for this page that's going to say bank
transfer you can call it whatever you
want to call it so i would use the
headline three bold text for that i'll
keep that there i would center this
horizontally actually to be sure it's at
the center horizontally and that's fine
now i would come here and i would have
this here so i would have these details
here so what i'll do is i'll make sure i
have one two three four okay
i would have
eight
row spaces there i'd have one two three
four five six seven eight
so what we are going to have here is a
destination account details where the
user should make the bank transfer to so
here is the account number here is the
account name and here is the bank name
and that's it so i would come here and i
would have a button component here i
would align it to the center and i would
stretch it to this point and stretch it
to this point also i would have one two
three four five six
so i have seven and eight
so i would have eight row spaces there
now what i would have on this button
will be
copy account number so the user can just
click on this button to copy
the account number here so i have sorted
the routes for funding the account on
this app with bank transfer so let's go
ahead and let's create the page where
the user will use to fund the account
with their debit card so i would come
here so i would change this debits debit
card i'll align this to the center
that's okay i'll take this out then i
would come here and i'll take this out
also
then i'd have all of this here so i
would have eight row spaces from this
icon also so let's zoom in so that we
can count better so i'll have one two
three four five six seven eight
i'll keep this here and i'll have one
two i'd have that there i'll zoom out
so this is going to be the page that
will enable the user fund their account
on this app with a debit card so what we
have here is the user will enter the
amount and have the option to select
that they want to use the existing card
that they have on this app or they would
like to add another card so let's fix
some alignment issues here let's keep
this there come here and keep this here
also then come here balance that's there
and keep that there also i would also
come here and make sure that this is
sorted also here so for the action of
adding another card we are going to see
how to do that as we proceed for now
let's go ahead and let's have a button
component here align that to the center
horizontally keep that there keep that
there then for the text i would say fund
account
and that's that so if the users click on
the fund accounts button they would have
this popup show up for them to choose
the method they want to use when they
select the bank transfer method they
would have this page show up if they
select the debit card method they would
have this page show up also they would
have this page show up
now if the user clicks on this fund
account button when they want to fund
the account with a debit card the user
will be taken to another page which is
going to indicate that the account has
been successfully funded so i'll
duplicate this to have that there now
before we work on that page i'd like to
change the name of this page from bank
transfer to debits
card transfer now for this page here i
would rename it to transfer successful
i'd come here i'll take all of this out
i'll take this out also and i'd have a
frame here which is going to be a
hundred by hundred frame let's see how
it's going to look like that's quite
small so i'll make this
240
by 240 and
i'll just work with this so i would give
it this color yeah and i'll give it a
corner reduce of 200 to make it a circle
and i'll go over to the feather icons
plugin and over here in the feather
icons plugin i'll bring in this icon and
that icon will be placed on top of this
frame now i would go ahead and i would
use the scale tool to scale that icon to
this point
just like this now when you scale the
icon make sure that the constraint of
that icon is set to the center
horizontally and the center vertically
so i would come here now i would select
this icon and i'll change the color of
that icon to this then i would have a
text here that would say count
funded successfully now you can have
whichever text you want to have there
that's fine so i would come here and
i'll change the color of this to that
so after that i would have a button
component here that will redirect the
user to the invest page so i would say
invest now when they get to this page
they would have the option to click on
the invest button here to go straight to
the invest page where they can invest so
that's the next page we are going to
look at we are going to look at creating
the invest page where the users can
invest in stocks so to create that page
it means that we need to create the
component that the page will need so
let's go ahead and let's see how to
create the components for that page so
for the invest page the first component
i would have there will be a little card
component that will be used to display
the cash amount that the user has so i
would come here and i would create that
this is the fund accounts component
section here
so i would have the invest component
section here and to create that card i
would have this here i would say cash
and i would use the body small textile
for that
and i'd have an amount here just any
amounts okay so i would use
body large board here
then i would select the both of them i
would create an auto layout on the both
of them make sure the padding around
items value is set to zero then i would
come here and i'd add a fill color to it
to have that now select the cache text
and set the horizontal resizing value to
fill container and do that for this
other text under here which is the
amount of cash that the user has now
when that's sorted select the auto
layout and then come here and set the
spacing between items value to four now
i'll go over to the feather icons plugin
and i'll look for an icon that i can use
to represent cache there so i'll scroll
down and i'll look for one of the icons
here
so i am going to make use of this icon
here i would select it i'll bring it
here then i would select both of these
and i would create an auto layout on the
both of them now i would come here and i
would make sure that the alignment value
for this auto layout is set to the top
left corner of the auto layout so i
would keep this auto layout selected i
would add a fill color to it and i would
set the spacing between items value to
eight then set the padding around items
value to eight then come here and i
would have the corner reduce value set
it also so over here i would select this
auto layout inside the main auto layout
now and i would set its horizontal
resizing value to fill container and
when i do that you would see that this
component will be a responsive component
just the way i want it to be now let's
go ahead and let's set the colors for
this so i would set the color for this
to that and i'll set this to this now
for this icon i would set the color for
this icon to this so i would keep this
here
i'll duplicate it when i duplicate it i
would go ahead change these to assets
then i'll leave the value here just like
this or you can change it if you want to
change it now the next thing i would
like to do is to take out that icon and
have another icon there so i'll go to
feather icons and i'll have this
selected for that so i'll bring this
here let's go to the layers tab here and
i would select the briefcase icon here
which is this i would select it here and
i'll take it into the frame 19 auto
layout just like this and you can see
that it is staying here on the right
side of the auto layout i would grab it
and i'll take it to the left side now i
would select this one and i'll delete it
and i have that so i would select this
icon now and i'll change
the color of this icon and this is
sorted so i would rename this to cash
card whatever you want to call it is
okay and i would rename this to assets
card and that's okay so i would select
this make it a component select this
make it a component so let's go ahead
and let's create the other components
that we are going to need on
the invest page so the next component i
would need on the invest page will be an
input field component that the user can
use to search for top stocks that they
would like to invest in so we have an
input field here already created it's
already a component so what i'm going to
do is i'll duplicate it i'll bring it
down here and i'll keep this here now
when you duplicate a component like this
the duplicate will be a child component
now i would love to work with this as a
child component so what i'm going to do
is out i would keep the component
selected right click on it and i would
select detach instance now when i select
detach instance you would see that this
is back to a regular auto layout so i
would come here and i would change the
name to search input field then what i'm
going to do is i'll go to feather icons
and i'll bring in a search icon which is
this i'll grab it and i'll drop it
inside this auto layout which is the
search input field auto layout now the
issue is this i want this search icon to
be smaller than this because it's quite
too big and as you can see it has
increased the height of the input field
so i'll keep the icon selected come here
and i'll set this to 12 and i'll set
this to 12. and there i have that now i
think 12 is too small i would set this
to 16 and i would set this to 16 and
that's sorted so the next thing is this
i would like this icon to stay on the
right side of this impute field so how
do we do that just select the search
input field auto layout come here click
on the alignment and padding property
then change this property from packed to
space between and that's going to be
sorted now let's change the color of
that icon i'll change it from black to
this now i can select it now and make it
a component and as you can see it can be
used just the way you'd like it to be
used so let's go ahead and let's create
the next component that we are going to
have on our invest page so the next
component will be the component that
will display the list of stocks that are
available to invest in in this app so
let's come here let's have some space
here i would use the brand fetch plugin
to pull up the logo of a brand i would
have this come here i would type in
dangote i'd press the enter key on my
keyboard and i would have this here so i
would select this
i would click on it to select it and i
would have it there in my canvas so i
would bring this here and i would make
it a 24 by 24 frame logo just like this
now when i make it 24 by 24 the next
thing i would love to have is the price
of this stock i would have that i would
select the caption text for that then i
would have this
then i would have this make sure i use
the caption text for that also then i
would create an auto layout on this and
i would set the padding around items
value to zero now i would select the
text inside this auto layout and i would
set its horizontal resizing value to
fill container now i would like to have
an icon here that will indicate decline
or increase so i would go to the feather
icons plugin and i would bring this icon
in and i'll place it here now i'll make
this icon a 16 by 16 icon just like this
when i place it here i would select both
of them and i would create an auto
layout on the both of them now for the
spacing between the auto layout it's
going to be set to 4. now i would select
this auto layout that's inside this
frame 19 auto layout i am talking about
the auto layout that has this number
here i would select it when i select it
i would set its horizontal resizing
value to fill container then i would
select the frame 19 auto layout now and
i'll add a fill color to it now let's go
ahead and let's select this icon
and let's make the color to be green
just to indicate progress here so i
would come here now i would select both
of these and i would create an auto
layout on the both of them now for this
auto layout here i would set the spacing
between items value to 8 it already set
it for me so i'll just leave it set to
eight then i would come here and i would
add a fill color to have this i would
come here i would select this text now
which is inside this new auto layout and
i would set its horizontal resizing
value to fill container and for this i
would set its horizontal resizing value
to fill container now when i select this
frame 20 auto layout as you can see here
it's a frame 20 auto layout when i
select it and i resize it you would see
that it's a responsive auto layout
just like this and that's what i want
actually so i'll bring this here now
i'll go ahead to create a text that will
signify the title of that stock i'll
just call it dang now i'd come here i
would set this to body large board and i
would have this stay here with this text
now what i'll do is i would select this
and this text and i would create an auto
layout on the both of them now i would
come here and i would add a fill color
to this auto layout first then come here
and align the content of that auto
layout to the center after that i would
set the spacing between items value of
that auto layout to eight to have this
now i would bring this here and i would
have this here the next thing to do is
to have all of these selected then i
would add an auto layout on all of them
now for this new auto layout now i would
set the spacing between items value to
it then come here select this auto
layout and set its horizontal resizing
value to fill container then i would
select the auto layout now and i would
add a fill color to it to have this now
for the padding around items value i
would set it to 8 and set the corner
reduce value to 8 just like this now if
i expand this you would see that i have
this component
looking just like this and this is ok so
i would select it i would name this to
stock list and i would make it a
component that's fine now the next
component i'd like to have there on the
invest page will be a component that
will be used to display the list of
stocks that the user have invested
literally the stock portfolio of the
user
so i would come here let's zoom in once
more i would have a 48 by 48 px frame
then i would give it a corner reduce of
100 to make it round then i would give
it this color now i would go
to the brand fetch plugins and i would
look for the base stack logo which is
this now i would come here i would right
click on this space stack logo i'd like
to take out the background color so i'll
use the remove bg plugin for that i'll
keep the logo selected and i'll make it
a 24 by 24px logo just like this and
i'll place it right at the center of
this circular frame that we have created
now when you place that on top of that
circular frame make sure to set the
constraint value for the horizontal axis
to the center and for the vertical axis
to the center so the next thing to do is
to go ahead and i would say
pay stack i would keep it selected come
here and i'll use the body large bold
text for that and right under this space
stack text i would have plus three four
five just to represent the appreciation
value of that stock so i'll keep it
selected and i would come here and i'll
go with the body small text now i would
make this to have a green color just
like this and for the paste stack text i
would make it to have this color so i
would select both of these first of all
create an auto layout make this spacing
between items value to be set for then
i'll select this text set it to fill
container and for this i'll set it to
fill container also now i'll expand this
and that's fine now the next thing to do
is to select all of these create an auto
layout on all of them when i create an
auto layout on this i would come here i
would set the spacing between items
value to eight and i would add a fill
color to that to have this now when i
set this to 8 i would come here and i
would set the padding around items value
to 8. now i'd like for us to check to
see if this is a responsive or to layout
and as you can see it's not and that's
because i have not set the horizontal
resizing value for this auto layout
inside of it
to fill container so when i set this to
fill container and i come here now you
would see that we have a responsive
layout so i would keep it selected i
would come here and i would set the
corner reduce value to it and there we
have our portfolio listing
component so i would say portfolio
portfolio list and i would click on
create component so i think we have
created all of the components that we
are going to need on our invest page so
at this stage i'd like for us to go
ahead and create our invest page so i
would come here now i would select this
i'll duplicate it i would rename this to
invest and i would come here i'll take
all of these out
and i'll leave the bottom navigation
component this time around i would come
here what i'd have first will be that
cash card so i would have one two three
four space before that let's say cash
card i'll bring the cash card in here
and for this cash card i'll change
the fill color of this cash card to this
i would select this and i'll change this
also to this i'll change the text color
here to this and for this i'll change
this
to that so i'll go ahead now and i'll
bring in the asset card and i'll do the
same to that also i'll come here
i'll change the color of that to this
and this will be changed to this
change this to this and this to this
and that's okay so what i'll do now is i
would arrange all of these to stay
organized so i like this to take up two
columns and i like this to come here and
take up two columns so let's zoom in to
be sure that this is properly organized
so this is not properly organized and
that's because i want four row spaces
before this so i'll bring this down here
when i select this i would have one two
three four
and this is okay so i'll bring this here
and i'll bring this down here
so this is sorted we have this section
sorted so the next section of this page
will be the section where i would write
a text
that's going to say top stocks to invest
in so i would have eight row spaces
before this
so i would say one two three four five
six seven eight and i'll have this stay
here now for the text here i would like
this text to be a body large text not a
body large bold text now after this text
i'd like to have that search field so i
would snap this to this point and i
would go ahead to bring in that search
input field which is this and i'll just
have only an 8px space between this text
here and the input field so i would come
here
i would stretch this to this point
and i'll change the placeholder to
sketch so let's change this from stock
to stocks and that's fine so the next
component i would like to have here is
the stock list component
so i would keep this here i'd actually
give it a shadow effect so that we can
see that clearly so
let's zoom in so i would give it two row
spaces one two and that's fine so i
would snap this perfectly and i would
like this stop here and i would like
this also to stop here let's zoom out so
i'll duplicate this i'll have this here
also and
let's duplicate this here let's
duplicate this here also so let's zoom
in to confirm that all our components
are aligned perfectly so you can see
this is okay this is okay
this is okay and this is okay so that
looks okay now i would have a stock
portfolio section now to differentiate
the two sections i would bring in the
button component and i would use it for
something different this time around so
i would have one two three four five six
seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve spaces so i would have
twelve row spaces here i would zoom out
i would stretch this to the end like
this i would come here and i would align
the content of this button now to the
left then i would set its top padding
value to it and the bottom padding value
to it
now what i would have here will be stock
portfolio now to make this look
different i would keep this selected
come here and i would set the corner
reduce value to zero just like this now
what are we going to have here we are
going to have the pay stack component
here so let's zoom in and let's make
sure this is properly organized so i'll
have one two three four space before
this and that's okay i would come here
and i'll give it a shadow effect just
like this now i would keep this selected
come here and i'll change the color so i
would come here i'll change the color to
this so the green color here needs to
actually be thicker than it is now just
like this so i'll make this to have two
columns
then i'll duplicate it
and have this stay here also taking up
two columns also now you can go ahead
and have other
stocks listed here that if you want to
have that
and here we are we are done with our
invest page now since we won't be able
to display all of the stock portfolio
here i would like to have a see all text
here so this see all text will be a
button text i'll keep it here and i'll
duplicate this see text and i'll keep it
here also and i'll change the color of
this see all text i'll change it to this
and that's fine now the next flow will
be this now let's assume a user likes
this stock here and the user wants to
invest in this talk it means the user
will click on the stock and the user
will be taken to the stock details page
right so let's make that happen i would
come here select this page and i'll
duplicate it come here and change
this to stock details and that's fine so
for the stock details page i'll take all
of these out and i'll zoom in then go to
the feather icons plugin to get that
icon that signifies going back to the
previous page and this is it i'll get it
i'll bring it here and i'll make sure
that this icon is actually inside the
stock details page and i'll take this to
this point and that's sorted now i'll
select the icon vector and i'll change
its color to this so what do we have
here i'd like for us to have a title
here that's going to say stock details
and this text should have a headline
three bold textile for it so i would
align it to the center horizontally and
that's okay now let's change the color
to this and that's fine so what i would
have here will be a component that i
would create i would just come here i
would have this frame tool selected and
i would create a frame with it like this
i'll set this to 8 then i would set the
color to this then i would set the color
to this then i would go to brand fetch
to get that logo and i'll place the logo
right on that frame layout that i just
created so i'll grab it and i'll place
it here now i'd keep it selected and
i'll set the horizontal constraint to
center and the vertical constraint to
center and that's okay so what i'll do
now is i'll keep this frame selected
rename this
to stock detail banner then i'd come
here and i'd make it a component so i
would go to that page now and over here
i would have that stock detail banner
component placed this is it here i'd
have it stay here i would stretch it to
this point and i'll stretch this at this
point that's okay so i would come here
now
let's snap that in and let's also make
sure that this is snapped in perfectly
just like this
so over here i have one two three and
let's make it four so over there i have
four row spaces between this stock
details text and this
stock detail banner component and that's
fine so let's zoom out the next thing
i'd have here will be the stock price
and the appreciation value i'll make
sure i have one two three four spaces
that's okay now i'll go ahead to create
a component
that i would place here and and that
component will go into more details
about this stock so let's go ahead and
let's create that component
so to create that component i would come
here and i would select the frame tool
now it creates a frame that's 42 px tall
just like this let's zoom into this
point
when i create this frame here i would
come over here and i would create a text
on this frame i would say my position
i'll keep this text here just like that
and that's fine now for this text i
would use the body small textile that i
have here which is this
and that's okay now i'll go ahead i
would create another text here i would
actually make this text box
to be this wide and i'd come here and
i'll just type in 35 now i'll keep this
text box selected now and i'll align the
content of that text box to stay at the
right select this frame layout now and
then make it an auto layout now i would
come here and i would click on the
alignment and
padding value and i would set the left
padding to 16 and set the right padding
to 16 then i would set the top padding
to 12 and the bottom padding to 12. now
i'd like this text to always stay here
and this text to always stay here so i
would come here and i'll change this
from
packed to space between and that's okay
so if i come here now you'd see that if
i take this in this is always staying
here and this is always staying here
same thing happens if i resize the left
side here just like this
and that's what i want actually so i'll
keep that selected then come here now
and select this text here
to make sure this is set to hog content
then come here and select this text to
make sure this is set to fixed width and
that's okay
so i would select this and i'll create
an auto layout on this auto layout now
just like this now this new auto layout
is called frame 25 yeah so inside this
new auto layout that i just created we
have this auto layout here which is
frame 24 i would select it and i'll
duplicate it vertically just like this
now i would select the frame 25 auto
layout then i would set the space
between the items inside the auto layout
to 4. when i do that i would come here
and i'll change the padding around items
value to 0 just to have that
now i would come here and i would set
the color for this frame 25 auto layout
to this now what i'll do is i would set
the corner reduce value for this auto
layout to eight now the corner reduce
won't be visible and that's because this
auto layout here is staying on top of
that auto layout so i would select this
auto layout here which is at the top and
i'll come here i would click on
independent corners here and i would set
the top left corner reduce value to
eight and i would set the top right
corner reduce value to eight just like
this i would come here i would select
this click on independent corners and i
would set the bottom right corner reduce
value to it and i would set the bottom
left corner reduce value to eight and
that's sorted now for each of these rows
here i would select this then come here
and i'll change its horizontal resizing
value to fill container i'll do that for
this also
do that for this also
and do that for this
and that's okay
now let's see if this
responding how we actually want it to
respond and it is actually now let's
edit these values that we have here
so i would come here
and i would set this to open
and i would set this to previous close
and i would set this
to market cap
now for this i'll change the value to
so i would come here previous close i
would say that plus this
and open
just any value there actually just any
value there will be fine actually so
with this i have successfully created
this component that i would use to show
more details about that stock so i would
come here and i'd call this
detail table
actually i would call it stock detail
table and i would save that then come
here and make it a component and here we
have that so i would zoom out and i
would go over to this page and i would
bring that component so let's come here
click on the assets tab come here grab
this and place it here so i would keep
it selected and i would add a shadow
effect just like this then zoom in so
that
i can calculate the row spaces better so
from this
item here i would like to have one two
three and four row spaces before this
let's zoom out and let's stretch this
to this point and that's fine so i can
go ahead select this text so that i'll
be able to change the colors i would
select all of this
come here and change this to that okay
this was not selected so i would change
it to that
and for this also i would change it
now the next component i would like to
have here will serve as links just in
case the user wishes to read more about
the stock and the company that owns this
stock so
i would go ahead and i would have that
it's going to be similar to what we have
here
now this is me creating this just the
same way i created this stock portfolio
component here the only difference here
is that
i just changed the color from what i
have here to this so let's zoom in to be
sure that we are placing our items
properly so i would come here i would
have one two three four row spaces
before this
and that's okay
so at the bottom here i would have a
button component
just for a user who is satisfied with
what they see here on this stock details
page and this button is going to be an
invest button so i would zoom in to
calculate the space better so i have one
two three four five six
row spaces here and i would like to stop
at
the sixth row space
and that's it
so if a user likes what they see here on
the stock details page
the user can go ahead and click on the
invest button if the user is not
satisfied the user can come here and
click on this button to go back to the
previous page where the user will still
have to see other stocks listed here so
that's it
so the next page here
will be the page that the user will go
to when the user clicks on this invest
button here i'd like us to go ahead and
create that page
so i would duplicate this
so i would come here i would rename this
to enter stock
amount
whatever you want to call it is okay
so i would come here i'll change this to
enter amount
and that's cool so i would go ahead and
i would have this here now this is me
using an input field and a button as
simple as that so i would zoom in to
this point and i would calculate the
space better
i would select this item and i would
calculate this space from that item i
would say one two three four five six so
i would like six row spaces there so i
would select this and i'll make sure
that snaps perfectly and that's it now
the space between this input field and
this button is one two three four and
that's fine i'll come here and i'll take
out this invest button and this page is
sorted now when the user enters the
amount that the user wishes to invest in
this stock with the user will go ahead
and click on this proceed button now
when the user clicks on this proceed
button the user will be taken to another
page now that page will be where the
user will be presented with a summary of
the investment that the user is about to
make now i would come here i would
select this and i would duplicate it and
i would
rename this to investments
summary now i'll zoom in
i would come here and i'll take all of
these out and i would have this here now
this is going to be
a summary of the investment that the
user is about to make
and if the user is okay with the summary
that the user sees here then the user
would go ahead and enter their secrets
pin here before they click on the invest
button to finally make the investment so
i would come here i would select all of
these and i would calculate the row
spaces better so i would come here i
would keep this here i would make sure
that i have let's zoom in i would make
sure that i have one two three four five
six row spaces there and that's cool so
i would zoom out to this point and this
page is sorted so this is the flow so
far
now when the user is on the home page
here
and the user wants to invest the user
will click on this invest link at
the bottom navigation here this is it
here at the bottom navigation here when
the user clicks on this link the user
will be taken to the invest page which
is this
and if the user goes through the list of
stocks that we have here and the user is
interested in investing in one of these
stocks let's say this one here the user
will go ahead to click on it and when
the user clicks on it the user will be
taken to the stock details page here
which is this now when the user is taken
to this page the user will read about
this stock
if the user likes what the user sees
here the user will go ahead and click on
the invest button here when the user
does that the user will be taken to this
page where the user will have to enter
the amount that the user wishes to
invest in that stock with now when the
user enters the amount here the user
will click on the proceed button here
when the user does that then the user
will be taken to this page where the
user will see a summary of the
investment that the user is about to
make then if the user is okay with this
the user will go ahead to enter their
secrets pin here when the user does that
the user will click on the invest button
here for the investment to be made
successfully so before we proceed
further i'd like to come here and change
this to
summary so i would keep that selected
and i would align it to the center
horizontally i would also come here
select this and make sure it's aligned
to the center horizontally now i'd come
to this page which is the invest page
and i'd like to have a title here
i'll change this to invest and i'll
align it to the center horizontally just
like that
now when the user clicks on this invest
button here the user will see a page
that says
investment successfully made or
investment made or whatever whatever
just a success message so i would come
here i would select this and i'll
duplicate it and i would rename this
successful investment and i'd save that
so what i'm going to have here will be
similar to what i have here so what i'll
do is i'll take out all that i have here
on this page
i'll take this out also
i was supposed to take this out also
this debit card title here i'll take
that out also i'll select all of this
i'll duplicate it and i'll bring this in
here just like this and i'll zoom in and
i'll just change this to success i'll
keep it selected and i'll align it to
the center horizontally now i'd come
here i would say go back home
and that's it
that's sorted
so so far so so far we have achieved the
authentication task we have achieved the
funding task and we have achieved the
investment task now we are going to go
ahead to create more screens that will
actually make the user experience on
this app to be better so one of those
screens will be the transaction details
page and that's the page that the user
will go to when the user clicks on any
of this card here under the recent
transactions section so if the user
clicks on this card for example the user
will be taken to a page where the user
will see the full details of this
transaction so let's go ahead and let's
create that page so i would come here i
would select this one here and i'll
duplicate it and i have that
so let's keep it selected come here and
let's call this transaction details and
for the transaction details page i'll
take this out and i'll take this out
now this is what i would have on this
transaction details page this is it as
simple as this so first things first
let's calculate our row space to be sure
that it's perfectly set so i would have
this here and i would count one two
three four five six so i like this to
start here one two three four five
six i would snap this correctly and i
would snap this correctly and that's
okay
so this here is to display the
transaction date that that transaction
happened so this is not complete
actually i can give some space here and
say
1603 just like that so that we will
depict the date and time of the
transaction and that's cool now what we
have here is the transaction amount and
here we have the amount in words here we
have the transaction type which is a
withdrawal here we have the transaction
remark which is for netflix and the
status of that transaction is successful
so i would select all of this zoom in
and i'll make sure i have one two three
four row spaces there now for the button
component here i would select this and i
would make sure i have one two three
four five six i would make sure i have
six row spaces there and that's fine so
if a user comes here and the user clicks
on one of these transactions
the user will go to a transaction
details page where the user will see
more details about that transaction so i
would go ahead and i would create other
pages that's going to make the
experience on this app to be better now
before we do that i would like to give
this transaction details page a page
title so i'll duplicate this and i'll
bring it here and i'll call that
transaction details i'll align it to the
center horizontally just like this
and that's fine so the next flow that i
would like to design will be the flow
that the user will go to when the user
clicks on this menu icon here now when
the user clicks on this menu icon i
would like for a menu bar to slide in
with other options that the user can use
to improve their experience on this app
so how do we make that happen it's
simple yeah so i would come here i would
have an iphone 13 pro max here i would
rename this to menu slide bar and i
would keep it selected come here and
i'll divide the width by two just like
this and i would have this so i might
decide to go ahead and increase this for
that and what i'll do is this i would
come here i would just have the logo
here and i would go ahead to have list
items of menu links so the first menu
link i would have here will be recent
transactions i'll keep that selected
here and i'll change this to a body
small text just like this now let's zoom
in let's keep this here i would keep it
selected and i would create an auto
layout on that text now this auto layout
i would like the auto layout to have a
padding around items value of 16 and i
would also like the alignment value to
be set to the left
so i would come here now i would keep
this here then create another auto
layout on top of it now this new auto
layout that i have created will have a
padding around items value
of zero just like this now i would come
here i would expand this new auto layout
here in the design 3. when i do that i
would select the recent transactions
auto layout and i'll duplicate it
just like this now i'll go ahead to edit
all of these to other links
before i do that let's select
the main auto layout now which is frame
34 here and let's set the spacing
between items value to four just to have
that
so the next link here will be
card management
i would have this be
investment
portfolio i would have this be request
statement and i would have this be
settings and that's fine so i would come
here i would select all of these text
and i'll change the color to this and
that's what we have so whenever the user
clicks on this menu icon this is going
to slide out from the left and that's
okay
so let's go ahead to create the routes
that the users will go to when the users
click on this transact link here at the
bottom navigation section so to do that
i would come here i would select this
here and i'll duplicate it i would
rename that to
transact now i would zoom in i would
come here and i would say
transact
keep that selected and i would align
that
to the center horizontally then i'll
take all of these out
now i would like to have two card
components here one for a withdrawal
action and one for a deposit action as
simple as that
so let's go ahead and let's create those
card components
so i would come here i would create a
text here i would say deposit
and i'll keep this text selected come
here and i'll go with
the headline three bold text
just like this now i would come here and
i would have a 48 by 48 px
frame layout
with a corner reduce of 100 then i would
come here and i would give it a color
that's green then go to
the feather icons plugin and i'll get an
incoming icon there which is this
this is our incoming arrow icon i'll
place this here then come here and set
the constraints value to center and
center now i'll select the icon vector
and i'll change the color to this so i
would bring this here select this and
then create an auto layout on it
now for this auto layout i would come
here and i would set the alignment
property to center when i do that i
would come here and i would set the
spacing between items value to 16 then
go ahead to add a fill color when i add
the fill color i would come here and i
would set the padding around items value
to 8 to have that then i would go ahead
to set the corner reduce value to eight
now i'd come here and i would select the
deposit text and
change the horizontal resizing value
from hog content to fill container so
this is the deposit action card that i
would have on that page i would come
here i would rename this to deposit
action
save that and then come here and click
on create component now i would select
this text and i'll change the color to
this
now i would come here now i would go to
this page and i would bring in that
component this is it i would keep it
selected and i would give it a shadow
effect i would zoom in to this point
i'll bring this here and i'll make sure
i have one two three four five six
row spaces
and that's okay
so i would stretch this to this point
like this and i would create a component
for withdrawal
i'll duplicate this component
which is the master component take note
and i would detach instance when i
detach instance i would select the
secular frame there i would make this
red i would select the arrow frame there
and i would set the rotation value to
180 degrees and that sorted as easy as
that so i would come here select it come
here
and go to the design three and rename
this to withdrawal action when i do that
i would keep it selected and i would
click on create component here and
that's okay so i would come here now i
would bring this in give it a shadow
effect
like this i would have this stay here
and i would spread this to this point
and that's okay
so finally on this page i would love to
have a button here that can be used to
perform the adding of card action so i
would keep this here i would have 16 px
margin space here which is two row
spaces
one and two i'll keep the button
selected i would set the top padding
value to it and the bottom padding value
to it then i'll change the text
content there to add card just like that
and that's sorted so this is the page
that the users will go to
when the users click on this transact
link here at the bottom navigation
component
so this is where i would stop for this
project in regards to creating screens
and i'll stop here because we have
achieved the actual user task for this
app now i'd like you to take this as
your own assignment and
and when you are done you can tag me to
it on twitter my twitter handle is
you can go ahead and tag me to your
assignment on twitter now the assignment
is this
i'd like you to have a notification icon
here and
the notification icon
should take users to a page of
notifications when they click on it
and the notifications can be anything it
can be newsletters it can be transaction
notifications it can be anything at all
now place the notification icon here and
create a notifications page that the
users will go to when the user clicks on
the notification icon now after that
come here and create a route or create a
page that the user will go to when the
user selects add another card create a
page that the user can use to add their
debit card details to this app
the third assignment will be this come
here and create a page that the user can
use to request for their statement
after that create a settings page now on
this settings page let the user be able
to set their secret spin there now over
here which is the card management link
the user should be able to delete a card
that they have added to this app or add
another card that they want to add to
this app
so that should be possible when the user
clicks on card management here this
should take the user to a page where
they will be able to see all the cards
that they have on this app and and also
they should have the ability on that
page to add and delete cards now take
note this add card button here should
take the user to the same page that you
would create for this add another card
here
just like that
and also this recent transactions link
here should take the users to a
dedicated page for the list of all
recent transactions
this investment portfolio link here
should take the user to a dedicated page
of all the investments that the user has
made on this app so go ahead to build
all of those pages so that you can have
a full and complete user experience now
finally for the assignment just before i
forget come here
and create a forgot password page create
a page here that the user can use to
reset their password just in case the
user forgets their password and that's
going to be it so at this stage what we
are going to do is to create a prototype
of all of these designs that we have
created we are going to link this
perfectly and see how it's going to work
so to do that let's zoom in i would come
here i would start from the splash
screen so i would select it come here
click on prototype when i click on
prototype i would come here and i would
connect this splash screen to this page
now the action will be an on tap action
and that's because this is a mobile app
actually so we are actually supposed to
tap this screen with our fingers now
when the user taps on the screen the
user should move to or should navigate
to you can see the action here should
navigate to the auth selection page
which is this now the transition
animation or the navigation animation
should be a smart animation so it's
going to be an ease in animation and i
would like this ease in animation to be
for 800 milliseconds actually i would
like this to be an easy in and out
animation just like this yeah that's
better for me so i would come here now
and i would say okay when the user
clicks on the login button here the user
should go to the login page and i'll
keep all of this set the way it is now
when the user clicks on the get started
button here the user should go to the
sign up page so i would come here click
on this login button here and i would
say when the user clicks on that login
button after
after passing in their email address and
password the user should go to the home
page which is this
over here when the user clicks on the
sign up button the user should go to the
verification page where the user will
have to enter the verification code sent
to their phone numbers now when the user
types in the
verification code here
the user should click on the verify
button and when the user clicks on the
verify button this should show like a
pop-up so i would connect it to this so
i would connect this and i would keep it
as on tap then for the action i would
have it set to open overlay then come
here and i'll keep it set as centered
actually after setting these to centered
i would come here and i won't select
this option and that's because i don't
want the user to close the popup if they
mistakenly click outside the popup i
would like the user to click on proceed
here so this other option here i would
select it this is the add background
behind overlay property or the add
background behind overlay option when i
select it it means that when the popup
shows up the background will be faded
so i would set the opacity value to 35
and i would like the animation to be an
instant animation and that's going to be
okay now when the user clicks on this
proceed button the user should be taken
to the home page now when you are
creating a prototype like this you can
just take the connection here to any
page at all then come here and set it to
the page you want to set it to so i
would come here and i would select home
and you can see that the connection has
gone to the home page just like this so
the authentication is set now when the
users come to the home page
and the users click on this menu icon
the user should be taken to the menu
slide bar frame here this is what should
show up when the user clicks on
that menu icon now i would want that
menu slide bar or that slide bar menu to
actually slide in from the left so i
would click on this connection here to
have the interaction details page show
up
now for the action here i would set this
to open overlay i would come here and i
would set it to manual when i set it to
manual it means i'll be the one to set
how the interaction is going to happen
so i would grab this and i'll place this
here just like this this is how it's
going to look like when you click on
that menu icon now i would come here and
i would say close this slide bar menu
when the user clicks outside of it i
would select that and over here i would
have a background behind overlay
property selected also and i would have
the opacity value set to 35
now for the animation i'll change this
from instant to move in just like this
and for the moving action i would have
it moving from the left
and i would have the speed of that
animation set to
milliseconds
now i would come here i would click on
this font account button here and i
would say okay when a user clicks on
this button this should show us a pop-up
so we all know how to set a pop-up right
so i'll change this to open overlay keep
it set centered and i would add a
background behind overlay action and
also if the user chooses not to fund the
account anymore the user can just click
outside the popup
and go back to the home page so i would
select that
i'll keep this set to 35 percent
and for the animation here i'll keep it
set to instant so i'll close this now if
the user
selects the bank transfer option the
user should come here
as easy as that and if the user clicks
on copy account number this account
number will be copied to the user's
clipboard and when that happens the user
will come here and click on this arrow
here to go back to the home page i would
set this from instant to smart animate
and that's okay so if the user clicks on
the debit card option here the user
would be taken to this page if the user
is taken to this page and the user types
in the amounts that they are trying to
actually fund the account with then the
user will go ahead to tap or to click on
the fund account button here and when
the user does that the user would come
to this page where the user will have a
message that says account funded
successfully now at this stage we are
going to want the user to go directly to
the invest page so i would select this
button now and i'll take this flow to
the invest page which is this so when
the user gets here i'll take this menu
icon out here actually when the user
gets here
and the user wants to invest in one of
these listed stocks let's see this one
the user will click on it and the user
will be taken to the stock details page
when the user gets to the stock details
page and the user is okay with all of
these details here the user will click
on the invest button here and when the
user does that the user will come here
and
be required to enter the amount that
they wish to invest in that stocks with
when the user enters the amount and the
user clicks on the proceed button the
user will be taken to this page which is
where the user will see a summary of the
investment that the user is about to
make
now if the user is satisfied with this
summary the user will go ahead to type
in their secret pin here and then click
on this invest button and when the user
does that the user will be taken to this
page which is
a success page that's going to let the
user know that hey you have successfully
invested in that stock so the user will
come here and click on the go back home
button and i would take this back to the
home page i would select home here
so let's come here and let's see
the other links that we have not created
so let's say the user is trying to see
the transaction detail of any of this
recent transaction here let's see the
withdrawal transaction here i would
click on it to select it
and i would link this to the transaction
details page which is this so if the
user clicks on that transaction card
there the user will be taken to this
page and if the user goes through the
whole detail and the user is satisfied
when the user clicks on done the user
will go back to the home page i would
come here and i would select home here
same will happen if the user comes here
clicks on that arrow the user will go
back to the home page so you can see
that we are creating lots of connections
and flows here lots of connections and
flows here so let's go back to the home
page and let's see the flow that we have
not created so this is the home page
here so this home link here is safe to
be there now let's say the user clicks
on this invest link here which is in the
bottom navigation component the user
should be taken to the invest page
if the user clicks on this transact link
here the user should be taken to the
transact page so if i come here now i
would still connect this this should go
to the home page and since this is the
invest page here it means we are here so
this should go to the transact page i'll
do that for this also so let's come here
let's see let's see what we have not
connected yet
so if the user comes to the
transact page and the user clicks on the
deposit
card here the user should have that
popup show up that would require them to
select if they want to deposit with bank
transfer or their debit card it should
be the same flow now over here i should
actually change this to withdraw
if the user clicks on this withdraw card
here the user should be taken to a page
where they would have to enter the
amount and the destination bank that
they are trying to withdraw their funds
too so this is also going to be a part
of your assignment go ahead and create
that flow when you create it go ahead
and tag me on twitter for my comment so
let's go ahead and let's present
this flow and let's see how it's going
to look like so i would come here i
would select the splash screen
and i would come here and click on
present
so when i click on present i would have
this splash screen show up here when i
click on it i would have the
option to either log in or get started
so i'll click on get started and here we
are on the sign up from page so if the
user enters their email address phone
number and password when the user clicks
on the sign up button the user will be
required to enter the verification code
when the user enters that the user will
click on the verify button here and a
pop-up will show up here saying phone
number verified now you'd see that when
i click outside the pop-up the pop-up
won't go away until i come here and i
click on the proceed button when i do
that i'll be taken to the home page now
here we are in the home page now if i
come here and i click on this menu icon
here you would see that this menu slide
bar or this slide bar menu anyhow you
call it is fine this slide bar menu
slides in from the left when i click
outside of it
it goes back in
now let's check the font account flow
when i click on it i would have this
popup show up here that says select
method now let's say i choose to select
the bank transfer method i would have
this show up here i'll be able to copy
the account number and when i'm done i
would come here and i would click on
this arrow icon here to go back to the
home page now let's click on the font
account button once more and let's
select the debit card method you can see
that i'll be taken to this page where i
would have to enter the amount that i'm
trying to fund this account with now
let's say i type in the amount i would
come here and i would click on the fund
account button
just like this and
i would have this message that says
account funded successfully now if i go
ahead and click on this invest button
i'll be taken to the invest page which
is this
and over here i would see a list of
stocks
now i would like to present this in full
screen actually so that we can see
better so over here i would see a list
of stocks that i can invest in now let's
say i'd like to invest in this one here
i would click on it and i would see full
details about this stock here now i
don't have some of my components showing
here so i would go back
to my design
i would come here so this is the stock
details pager so these three buttons
actually not inside that layout so i
would select the three of them and i'll
take them inside that layout and that's
sorted now when i come back here you
would see that i have that here so let's
go back to our full screen presentation
so if the user likes what they see here
in the stock details page the user will
go ahead to click on the invest button
here and when the user does that the
user will enter the amount that they
would like to invest in that stocks with
when the user does that the user will go
ahead to click on the proceed button
here now that flow is not created
so i would come back to our design here
i would click on this proceed button
here click on prototype and i would see
what the problem is so i came here and i
clicked on this connection link here and
i changed this from on drag to on tab
now when i come back here and i click on
the proceed button here you would see
that we are taken to this summary page
now this page will be the page where the
user will see a summary of the
investment that the user is about to
make and if the user is okay with this
the user will go ahead to enter
their secret pin here and then click on
the invest button now the invest button
is not active also i would come here and
i would see the problem for that so i
would click on invest here and i would
select the connection flow here and as
you can see here
there is an on drag
event here i would come here and i'll
delete that on drag event here and i'll
just leave this set to tap
now but the tap event there is no
navigation destination so i would set
this first of all i would take note of
this screen here this is the successful
investment page so i would come here and
i would go to the successful investment
page and that's sorted now when i come
here and i click on invest i'll be taken
to this success page now when i click on
go back home
i'll be taken back to the home page now
that is after i have successfully
invested in a stock
now
what happens if i come here and i click
on one of the recent transactions here
let's see the withdrawal transaction
here you would see that i'll be taken to
the transaction details page for that
transaction when i'm done going through
it i'll click on done and i'll be taken
back to the home page now what's going
to happen if i come here and i click on
this invest link at the bottom
navigation component i'll be taken to
the invest page still and i'll be able
to still invest
in a stock
just like this now what happens if i
come here and i click on the transact
link here i'll be taken to this page
where i would have the option to deposit
funds or withdraw funds and i would also
have the option to add card now if i am
okay with this here i would come here
and i would click on this arrow to go
back to the home page and that arrow is
not active so i would
have that sorted i would come here i
would connect that arrow
to the home page
and it's going to be an untapped event
so when i come back here when i click on
that arrow now you would see that i am
taken back to the homepage so go ahead
create the other pages and the other
routes as your assignment
then tag me to it on twitter so that's
that for this course
if you found this course to be helpful
go ahead click on the subscribe button
leave a comment in the comment section
and stay tuned for more content
thank you and see you in another course